thank you
good morning my lady Matt Hancock MP
please
I do solemnly
sincerely and truly declare and affirm
declare and affirm at the evidence again
the evidence I shall give
it shall be the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
could you give the inquiry please your
full name yes I'm my full name is
Matthew John David Hancock
Mr Hancock thank you for attending today
whilst you give evidence could you
please
speak up so that we may all hear you
clearly and also so that the
photographer can hear you for the
purposes of the transcript
if I ask a question that is not clear
please don't hesitate to ask me to
repeat it
there will be a break in the course of
the mornings evidence session
you have kindly provided a witness
statement
dated the 20th of April of this year is
that right that's right yes could we
have please on the screen one eight one
eight two five
thank you
foreign
page 14 please
at page 24 I think is the last page
signed I think on the 12th of May
therefore and uh it was accompanied by
the usual statement of Truth
Mr Hancock you were paymaster General
and Minister for the cabinet office
between the 11th of May 2015 and
July 16th yes and during that time were
you therefore responsible ministerially
for
an important part of this pandemic
preparedness
structure namely
the National Security risk assessment
process yes I was formerly the junior
Minister responsible for uh for that
both for the secret part and for the
national risk register and I reported to
Oliver lettwin
um and he in practice LED on those areas
but nevertheless I had Junior oversight
of them and is that because the senior
minister in that regard is the
chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
which he was and you were the junior
ministerial colleague as Minister for
the candidate office I was effectively
the number two in the cabinet office yes
and then did you become Secretary of
State at the Department of Health and
Social care
between the 9th of July 2018 when you
took over from Jeremy Hunt MP and the
26th of June 2021 when you resigned yes
my lady for the purposes of uh for those
who may be listening to Mr Hancock's
evidence I'm going to make clear that
your appearance today
is obviously concerned with the
dischargeable functions as the minister
for the cabinet office under Secretary
of State in the Department of Health and
Social care
pre-pandemic yes we are concerned today
only with the issues of emergency
planning and preparedness
and so Maya made clear that I will not
be asking you questions about
detail of non-pharmaceutical
interventions lockdowns the government's
response or the test and Trace or
procurement or PPE issues which arose
after the pandemic struck
they will come in later modules they
will all be in NATO modules
particularly module two in the in the
Autumn for which Mr Hancock has already
provided a draft statement
eprr pandemic planning
the functions of the Secretary of State
Mr Hancock in relation to pandemic
planning are
wide-ranging and complex are they not
there is quite a lot
to be concerned with in this field
um yes and that is in addition to the
very broad responsibilities overall as
Secretary of State
you are responsible or were responsible
in Broad terms for Health and Social
care and that includes therefore
Health protection Health Improvement the
Healthcare Systems the social Care
Systems although that's largely in the
hands of local authorities and and most
importantly perhaps the NHS so it's a
very wide brief indeed
I wouldn't say most importantly the NHS
I'd say that there are many many areas
of importance and actually one of the
challenges of the job is to try to put
your attention to the most important
areas because it is so broad
is a vital function of the Secretary of
State to deal with health emergencies at
absolutely and going into the job
I had some experience at a more junior
level of dealing with crises and
emergencies and so I took my
responsibilities as the
as the principal responder to a pandemic
very seriously
does dealing with health emergencies
include dealing with infectious diseases
being ready to deal with the risk of
infectious diseases absolutely
so
when concerned in the field of emergency
preparedness
resilience civil contingencies
where there is a health emergency
it is the Department of Health and
Social care that is the lead government
Department in effect it is the
department in the driving seat yes and
as Secretary of State uh I felt keenly
the responsibility as essentially the
lead responder in the first instance to
those sorts of Health emergencies and it
was a
um it was a part of my day-to-day work
because these emergencies happen from
time to time
were
when you were Secretary of State risks
prioritized in any way was there a
grading system to prioritize those most
important and and serious risks from
those that were less so yes of course
that's absolutely vital and one of the
challenges in a system as big as the
health system is making sure the
decisions are taken at the right level
because if you escalated everything to
the Secretary of State they whoever they
are they would be completely overwhelmed
um yet it's vital to escalate the things
that need to be seen by the Secretary of
State to the uh to their desk
was influenza pandemic prioritized as a
tier one risk yes it was uh on I recall
that on my first day I was given a
briefing document about as big as this
one and one of the elements of it was
making clear my responsibility as a as
the tier one National responder for a
pandemic flu and for other
infectious diseases I was already aware
of this element of the role from my time
at the cabinet office but nevertheless
it was properly informally brought to my
attention and on day one I asked for
more information on preparedness because
I having been involved in previous
crises for instance at the bank of
England in before I went into politics I
knew that when things go wrong things
move quickly and you need to be as well
prepared as you can
at the highest level of the department
was there a board known as the
departmental board
which looked at the highest level on the
major risks confronting the department
yes and the the role of the departmental
board was to ensure that the department
was structuring itself properly to deal
with the different challenges that it
faced may we have please two three one
four two which is a copy of your
Department's then high level risk
register
for quarter 3 2019-20
and go to the top of the page
we will see there
the years
2019-20 quarter three high level risk
register and if you go to the far left
hand side of the page there will be a
number of Road numbers
if you could scroll down please to row
there are two names on the left in the
uh the column second from the left Mr
Hancock Emma Reed and Clara Swinson both
of whom have been Witnesses before
inquiry
the description major national
infectious disease outbreak and pandemic
flu
and the risk identified for self-evident
reasons is that the department fails to
respond and mobilize adequately to a
major national infectious disease Hazard
such as pandemic flu or other novel
infection
and
the approach taken the response on the
part of the department
is in the next column to manage the risk
and likely domestic impact of a major
pandemic flu or emerging infectious
disease outbreak
so the risk was identified in terms not
just
of the pandemic being a influenza
pandemic but obviously the risk of an
infectious disease outbreak in emerging
infectious disease outbreak yes
does its presence in that chart in that
schedule Mr hanco indicate the
seriousness with which the department
took the risk of a major infectious
disease outbreak
or and or pandemic flu
yes and the red rating demonstrates that
the significance of the impact of this
should It Strike could be very serious
and the day-to-day life of a health
secretary involves
uh being aware of and from time to time
being involved in managing the response
to potential infectious disease risks
which happen from time to time and I set
out in my statement that over the Autumn
of 2019 and there was a potential flu
outbreak there was a uh what's now known
as mpox outbreak then known as monkey
pox
um and over this period we were also
dealing with the Ebola epidemic in
Western central Africa and the
particular responsibility of the health
department was to ensure that we were
prepared should Ebola come to the to the
UK so this was a this was not a
theoretical exercise it was part of the
day-to-day job of being Health secretary
it is Apparent from the document
that in relation to each risk identified
on the left of the schedule
a number of what's known as mitigations
are put in place in order to manage the
risk
in other words the department sets out
in Collins k l m n in respect of each
risk
what the department is doing to manage
the risk to mitigate it to ensure that
either that the risk
does not eventuate it does not come to
pass or to manage the consequences of
whatever it is that the risk amounts to
um
the the consequences can be managed
do you happen to know why in this risk
register there is no mitigation set out
in respect of that row 11 risk
no I don't know
um why those boxes are empty but I do
know that there was significant activity
underway both in the department and in
public health England
to make sure that
um we were prepared
um as prepared as then thought possible
now come on to that because it's
absolutely Central that question
um and frankly
um it was a it was a regular occurrence
to deal with these sorts of Novel
infectious diseases and threats
um so it was it was something that
happened all the time do you recall Mr
Hancock any particular departmental
board
which presumably you attended at which
the row 11 risk of a major national
infectious disease and pandemic flu was
actively debated no
do you have any recollection
of the debates surrounding this
particular risk at departmental boards I
mean obviously a great deal
many points go across the Secretary of
State's desk but but do you have any
personal recollection of I don't at the
departmental board
um but I also wouldn't have expected it
to be debated at the departmental board
um because the departmental board was
focused on ensuring that there was
appropriate resource in place for any of
the different
risks that the department faced
um and the ensuring that the department
was set up to respond not to do the
responding it self it's an important
distinction in terms of how the board
operated and what its job was
um and um
I was aware from the day one brief
onwards of the work that was that was
underway so there's no substantive
reason these boxes should be empty and
and uh I think it would be wrong to read
from
this which I don't recall
um myself
um this implying that there wasn't work
ongoing because as you can see from the
other paperwork there was my question
was in fact to ask you whether you
recollected what was being done
in terms of was there a debate about as
you say the processes that needed to be
put into place was there a debate about
what needed to be set up to mitigate
this risk
at a departmental board level there was
a departmental level there was not from
my my recollection at the board but that
I don't think the board would have been
there would have been the normal place
to have had such discussion
well Mr ankle that that cannot be right
can it because this is a schedule of the
high level risks which were put before
the departmental board and therefore it
must follow
that these are risks and mitigations
which are debated by the departmental
board that is what this chart shows
the purpose of the board was to ensure
that the department was doing what
needed to happen rather than to debate
the substance of it all right
you've referred to the fact that the
Department of Health and Social care was
the lead government Department
when it comes to dealing with planning
and preparedness for a health emergency
and also
in relation to the necessary response
as a secretary of state what did you
understand
that responsibility to consist of what
what did lead government Department in
the Civil contingencies field mean to
you oh it means that if that risk
it begins to materialize
it is the Department's responsibility to
appropriately it is also before that
stage the Department's responsibility to
have adequate surveillance to that sort
of risk
um and therefore as Secretary of State
it was my responsibility to ensure
as much as possible given all the other
pressures
that there was adequate
um oversight
and did that oversight comprise matters
such as
ensuring that the department played its
proper part in
the risk assessment process yes owning
to use a terrible phrase the risks for
which the department was responsible
dealing with capability the how to
respond to risks eventuating contingency
and emergency planning in response to
again those risks and building up the
Department's own resilience how it would
cope
with the impact of one or more of these
risks yes and bringing all of that to
the attention of the rest of government
should action be needed elsewhere in
government in addition indeed so
focusing
firstly please or one of those errors
the risk assessment area
when you joined the Department as
Secretary of State you you wouldn't I
think have been
engaged in the nsra process the risk
assessment process because one wasn't
produced after you took office until
2019 correct when the nsra and NRA
processors brought together but do you
recall the detail of that
process do you recall specific debate
about the contents of that 2019
cabinet office produced risk assessment
no I was not involved in those debates
and there was an nsra and nrr published
in 2015 just before I joined the cabinet
office so when I joined the cabinet
office with responsibility for that area
a significant piece of work had just
been concluded which have been led by
Oliver letwin I of course was aware of
and read those documents at the time but
then was not aware of the next iteration
of that work going on and as you say
there wasn't a publication in that area
um for a number of years and in any case
the
um the language in those documents as
they were
Revisited over the years was essentially
the same which is that the category one
top risk was
um pandemic influenza and then there was
a also consideration of other infectious
diseases and external
external threats and
um I know there's been significant
discussion so far at the inquiry on the
of the focus on influenza pandemic
um I was told that the reason that was
the category one risk is because it's
the most likely uh pandemic but of
course we were aware of other infectious
diseases not least because we were
actively involved in responding to Ebola
and
um to a lesser extent uh mpox and the
and phe had a day-to-day responsibility
for other infectious diseases that tend
to happen in much smaller numbers like
Legionnaires disease so
um I was aware of it both from the work
in the formal production of those risk
assessments and in the day-to-day work
of the department
when you join the department you you
were as you say provided with
uh I think it's called a day one high
level briefing yeah
may we please have one eight three three
three four on the screen and
this pack first day pack included a
briefing from the permanent secretary
sir Chris wormald and a number of other
senior officials in your department and
a number of documents
could we please have page one
at e if you could highlight that please
was one of the areas on which you were
briefed Global and public health and
that briefing was delivered by Clara
Swinson then a deputy
uh that's a director General director
general of one of the directorates in
the in the department
page 10
there is the the section on global and
Public Health
if you could scroll down the page please
to paragraph five the main work areas in
the group are
and then the first bullet point
emergency preparedness and health
protection director Emma Reed this
directorate prepares form responds to
emergencies including Cobra and works on
the government's prevent strategy
practices for terrorists or other
threats such as pandemic
National immunization and screening
programs
it also runs a global Health security
program supporting middle and low-income
countries
there was no reference there in that
first day briefing pack to the level of
risk that pandemic flu posed so there's
no reference to tier one
the risk that you've identified in
relation to pandemic flu
were you provided
either on that day or later with more
detail concerning the risk that pandemic
flu posed did you in fact ask to be
better briefed in relation to what the
risks to the department were in relation
to
pandemic threat yes I I remember this
document I remember reading it and on
the first evening as health secretary I
wrote on this particular paragraph to
say more details please
um as you can imagine I was going
through this document working out which
areas I needed to focus on
um because you have to choose what to
focus on and this was an area that I
knew I needed to be across
so you called for more information and a
written response was provided by I think
Emma Reid 184 105 please
foreign
introduction to emergency preparedness
resilience and response eprr
and on that first page
we can see in paragraph one a reference
to the fact that the dhsc in conjunction
with NHS England and public health
England must provide a coordinated
response to the challenge of risks set
out in the National risk assessment such
as natural hazards and of course natural
hazards includes does enormous to
Hancock the risk of pandemic flu yes
and you can see their references to the
department coordinating Health response
to the incidents in in Salisbury and
Amesbury
if you could go further down the page
please
emergency preparedness above paragraph
six this civil contingencies act 2004
outlines the national response to civil
emergencies establishing roles and
responsibilities for those involved in
emergency preparation and response
at the local level there is then a
reference to the division in the act the
bifurcation between category 1 and
Category 2 responders and you as the
Secretary of State were a category one
responder were you not yes and then
paragraph seven please
category 1 responders are required to
carry out exercises and training and
staff in emergency planning
the dhsc participates in a
cross-government program of exercises
and ministers will be invited to
participate in tier one exercises and to
participate in Cobra style meetings
which subsequently became aware of the
fact that the had in 2016 in October of
that year
been an exercise exercise cygnus yes
which was
a exercise designed to test the United
Kingdom systems to deal with pandemic
influenza yes and
a stand called there's obviously ample
material to show that you became aware
of exercise cygnus yeah and and it was
an important part of your departmental
functions
looking back
are you surprised that in this more
detailed briefing
there was no reference to the fact that
just a year before
exercise cygnus had reported and in
general terms had found that the plans
and capabilities of the United Kingdom
were not sufficient to deal with the
likely demands of a severe pandemic
but that's a good question I don't know
why that's not written here I did I was
aware became aware of
um exercise sickness and the work that
was being done to put his
recommendations into a
I mean there's a bigger challenge with
exercise sickness which perhaps we'll
come on to of course
in your witness statement you say that
um
you ask for further
yes briefings to be prepared having read
this document can you now recall what
areas concerned you and
what areas you asked to be addressed by
way of further briefing materials yes I
wanted to know about the Department's
preparation
and it's
um it's planning processes and I asked
for a so I asked for further information
based on
I recall receiving a note in I think it
was in August 2018
um and continued to ask questions for
instance one of the areas that I pushed
hard on was the lack of UK domestic
vaccine manufacturing given the
importance of that a vaccine to
responding to any pandemic and that was
an area that I worked on intensively up
to the up up up until the pandemic
struck and obviously then thereafter so
um this was a program of work
for me
which was
um on which I iterated with the with the
team I kept asking more questions and
had
um meetings on it and the area that I
focused on was on the vaccine
manufacturing point and others
alongside this I was also assured that
the UK was one of the best placed
countries in the world for responding to
a pandemic and indeed in some areas
categorized by the World Health
Organization as the best place in the
world so just to give context to these
this the you know this interaction
between me as the new sector of state
and my officials at the same time you
haven't brought it up but in one of the
documents I got very early on it stated
clearly that we are well prepared and
that wasn't the civil servants
um own assessment that was the World
Health Organization assessment of the UK
and I know that Mr Hunt referred to that
last week but you know when you become
the secretary of state you think about
the challenges in front of you in my
case
I had a background in technology in the
NHS desperately needed better technology
the NHS needed people and we needed to
be better at prevention of ill health
across the board of course prevention of
a pandemic is part of that but there's
also a huge focus on for instance
obesity I took those as my three
priorities I continued the work on uh on
the protection from these threats but
it's important to
um to focus and you can understand that
when you're assured by the leading
Global Authority that the UK is the best
prepared in the world that is quite a
significant reassurance that turned out
to be wrong
coming back to the internal briefing yes
putting us to one side what
international authorities said about the
United Kingdom's position
you've told us that
there was therefore a debate with your
civil servants about vaccines that was
one of the the issues yes
when you were told
however by your civil servants that the
United Kingdom was well prepared yes
what did they say when you asked them as
you presumably did well in in what way
are we prepared yes what did they say
about the various other parts of the
preparedness structure
stockpiles yes diagnostic testing
plans for quarantining or shielding or
to deal with the impact of a pandemic or
the supply of antivirals all of which
are other aspects of the system of
preparedness
um well I'm happy you told I I was told
that we had plans in these areas
um so for instance on stockpiles I was
told that we had a very significant
stockpile of PPE and we did the problem
was that it was extremely hard to get it
out fast enough when the crisis hit I
was told that we were good at developing
tests and indeed we were we were we
developed a test in the first few days
after the genetic code of covid-19 was
published the problem was there was no
plan in place to scale testing that had
any
um that was that we could execute
um on antivirals we had a stockpile of
antivirals for a flu
but not for a coronavirus on vaccines I
was concerned that we weren't in a
strong enough position because we're
reliant on manufacturing vaccines
overseas and I thought that in a
pandemic scenario Force Meyer would mean
it would be hard to get hold of vaccine
doses if they are physically
manufactured overseas no matter what our
contracts said and so I insisted that we
pushed on domestic manufacture and
sought the funding to deliver on that a
pro a plan was already in
um early development to make that
happen so in each of these cases there
was a plan but the absolutely Central
problem with the planning in the UK
was that the doctrine was wrong and if I
maybe I should set this out now in my
I've written it in my written statement
the attitude the doctrine of the UK
was to plan
for the consequences of a disaster
can we buy enough body bags where are we
going to bury the dead
and that was completely wrong
of course it's important to have that in
case
you fail to stop a pandemic But Central
to pandemic planning needs to be how do
you stop the disaster from happening in
the first place how do you suppress the
virus
and I need to put on the record if I'm a
my lady that my written statement I've
got an update on my written statement
having continued to look through the
documents in Mr hanco will return if we
may to correcting one or two parts of
your winner statement okay later I'm
aware that there were one or two errors
that you want to say something more
about in light of documentation which
you've been provided with more recently
can I bring you back please though to
the debate with your civil servants
about the state of preparedness yeah
Do You observe to your civil servants or
ask
well there is a significant stockpile
but it's only for flu
well in the case of PPE
the distinction between a flu pandemic
and a coronavirus pandemic is really a
second order
um a respiratory disease pandemic
requires very similar or in many many
cases the same PPE irrespective of the
virology what matters is the
characteristic of the virus indeed
did you ask
whether or not the stockpile about which
you received assurances would be
adequate for a non-influenza pandemic
um I don't recall whether I did or not
but I also know that if I'd ask the
question I would have been I hopefully
would have been told it's adequate for
other respiratory diseases as well
because indeed it was because we used it
did you ask whether or not the
antivirals
yes in the main a brand antiviral called
Tamiflu yes which was supplied in was
available in large quantities whether
that was suitable for a non-influenza
pandemic I don't know whether I asked or
I was brief but I was certainly aware
that that was only useful against a flu
not a Coronavirus
you ask or were you made aware that the
testing the diagnostic testing which in
place was on a very small order and of
course was testing designed to deal with
a limited High consequence infectious
disease primarily one involving an
outbreak in health settings yes I knew
that the testing system was
small and the the reason that I
um explained the flawed Doctrine
at this point
is that
by not preparing to stop a pandemic and
worse by explicitly stating in the
planning that it would not be possible
to stop a pandemic
um therefore a huge amount of other
things that need to happen when you're
trying to stop a pandemic didn't happen
and we had to build them from scratch
when the pandemic struck for instance
large-scale testing did not exist
and a large-scale contact tracing did
not exist because it was assumed that as
soon as there was Community transmission
it wouldn't be possible to stop the
spread and therefore what's the point in
contact racing that was completely wrong
and it in my view is the absolutely
Central lesson is of course the
difference between a flu and a
coronavirus is important but it is a but
it is not nearly as important as getting
the doctrine right so in future we're
ready to suppress a a pandemic
unless the costs of lockdown are greater
than the costs that the PA that the
pandemic would bring perhaps we'll
return to the issue of them or the
doctrinal arguments about lockdowns a
little later if I may the reason to
bring it up is because it had
consequences in all the areas you set
out stockpiles testing antivirals
contact tracing and and much more widely
those were now the acknowledged
consequences of the doctrinal failure Mr
Hancock yes
but why if you ask the questions which
you say now you did about the fact that
antivirals and the stockpiles of
antivirals were only suitable for
influenza
that the testing was limited and
suitable for high consequence infectious
disease in a healthcare setting
that the PPE was designed for flu
although it had an application to hcids
as well
and that there was no debate about
potential countermeasures mandatory
quarantining shielding the impact on
education or the economy
if these were questions which were posed
when you took office in July 18. why was
the situation allowed to develop in
which none of these matters were
met addressed by the time you had to
deal with the consequences of the
pandemic in February 2020 when as you've
rightly said
you had to build in all these areas the
entire system from scratch because I was
assured that the UK planning
was
among the best and in some instances the
best in the world
and of course with hindsight
I wish I'd spent that short period of
time
as health secretary before the plan
pandemic struck
also changing the entire attitude to how
we respond to a pandemic and perhaps you
know one of the reasons that I feel so
strongly about the importance of this
inquiry and why I'm so emotionally
committed to making sure that it's a
success with full transparency and total
brutal honesty
and answering your questions to get to
the bottom of this is because
these because of these uh this huge era
in the
doctrine that the UK and by the way the
whole Western World had in how to tackle
a a pandemic and that
that flawed Doctrine underpinned many of
the problems that made it extremely
difficult to respond and if I may say so
I am profoundly sorry for the impact
that had I'm profoundly sorry for each
death that has occurred and I also
understand
why for some it will be
hard to take that apology from me I
understand that I get it
but it is honest and heartfelt and I'm
not very good at talking about my
emotions and how I feel
um but that is
honest and true
um and all I can do
is ensure that this inquiry gets to the
bottom of it and that for the future we
learn the right lessons
so that we stop a pandemic in its tracks
much much earlier
and that we have the systems in place
ready to do that and because I'm worried
that they're being dismantled as we
speak well we'll come to that in a
moment Mr Hancock
so with with those
words in mind why in July 2018
when you were made aware of the Lacuna
in the system of preparedness the
absence of stockpiled PPE for
non-influenza pandemic the lack of
antiviral the lack of mass diagnostic
testing massive contact
Trace systems
why did you not pursue those issues
in the following 18 months before the
pandemic struck
the only answer I can give is because I
was assured that we had the best system
in place in the world
um and because the system was working
towards
an approach to pandemic response that
was wrong that's why it was built that
way and that flaw that failure went back
years and years and was embedded in the
entire system response Mr Hancock
forgive me
that doctrinal error to which will come
in a moment in the 2011 strategy
explains why the position was as it was
in July 18. my question to you though is
why having been alerted to these serious
issues
was more not done over the following 18
months regardless of why you're in that
position regardless of why the
department was in that position
regardless of the doctrinal foundation
why were those practical
considerations not followed through well
there was there was no recommendation to
resolve those problems that I was aware
of there were recommendations to put
into place the learnings from Project
sickness
some but not all of which were taken
forward I was assured that there was a
program of work to put those in place
um but there was there were no
recommendations to build a testing
system that I was aware of there was no
recommendations to
um change the stockpile although on that
point
the stockpile was effectively
transferable from one respiratory
disease to another
um these these recommendations were not
there because the system was geared
towards how to how to clear up after a
disaster not prevented you were the
Secretary of State yes
it doesn't need a formal submission from
civil servants for something to be done
if in the course of this debate you
asked your civil sermons
where are the antivirals for a
non-influenza pandemic yes where is the
stockpile for a non-influenza pandemic
where are the plans for Mass testing
they wouldn't have said Secretary of
State we can't do anything about that
let's wait to see what submission we
draw up recommends you could have
ordered it to be addressed and you could
have pursued and hurried them until
something was done and of course had I
known the pandemic was about to strike
then
I would have done that but this was an
unprecedented pandemic and the uh nobody
was to know so I all I can explain is
that when you're when you are when you
become the secretary say when you are
the Secretary of State new in post
there are a significant number of
recommendations of what needs to be
changed
um for instance Sally Davies came into
my office and said we have to try to
prevent more and prevent ill health and
Tackle obesity that is the number one
problem facing the country this was not
regarded as a number one problem that
needed to be fixed because we were
regarded by external organizations that
had been investigated our preparedness
we were regarded as one of the best in
the in the world that's the only answer
I can give you I know I've repeated it
but that's because it's true
the 2011 strategy to which you refer was
the 2011 influenza strategy
document
dealing as it says on its face with the
strategy for a influenza pandemic yes
there was only ever one strategy
document wasn't there that was it
that was the strategy document that I
was aware of of course it was a whole
load of underpinning and documents and
further work but that was the strategy
document yes and that's single strategy
document identified no strategy for a
non-influenza pandemic other than the
hope
that the plan for a influenza pandemic
could be modified to deal with high
consequence infectious disease that was
not influenza
that's right I would also say
that any pandemic by its nature is a
novel disease indeed and so you cannot
have a plan precisely for the disease
that comes and the things that matter
are how long is the incubation period
how transmissible is it how does it
transmit and crucially who does it
affect more than others what are the
inequalities
the consequences of this disease
those are the factors that matter and
and it will be far better to have a
respiratory disease plan and a
blood-borne pandemic disease plan and a
vector I touch born a touch-borne
disease plan
um that was non-specific about the the
virology of the pathogen because the
because what matters is how the things
transmitted and how
um and how it affects people uh
as much as the as the underlying
virology as well so in effect the plan
failed to provide for a range of
scenarios it focused too much upon an
influenza pandemic of course that's what
it was called and
although there was a reference in it Mr
Hancock
to the inherent unpredictability
of respiratory viruses
there was no
detail was that
of how
given those inherent
unreliable characteristics of of a
respiratory virus
we could be hit by a non-influenza
pandemic
which had different characteristics to
influenza but could be no less
catastrophic so that was the flaw wasn't
it that was not the main floor
that was a flaw
um that was of course
a problem
um
however
we did we also knew there could be
another
um infectious disease and as I've
mentioned we were dealing with a number
of them and I was cognizant of that for
instance when we did the work on uh on
vaccine production the plan that was put
together was a pandemic disease
plan vaccine plan not an influenza
pandemic vaccine plan so we were
cognizant of that but I returned to my
central point which is that to say that
the main problem with that plan was that
it was a flu plan and there was and we
ended up with a coronavirus pandemic is
of course a a flaw but it is not the
central floor if we'd had a flu pandemic
we would have had
a massive problem because of the
doctrinal failure of how to respond to
it as well that was a much bigger error
it was an error Across the Western world
but it was a much bigger error and it is
absolutely Central and I know that I
keep stressing this point but it is
Central to what we must learn as a
country that we've got to be ready to
hit a pandemic hard that we've got to be
able to take action lockdown action if
necessary that is wider earlier more
stringent than feels comfortable at the
time and the failure to plan for that
was a much bigger flaw in the strategy
than the fact that it was targeted at
the wrong disease
they were both major flaws in the
strategy where they're not Mr Hancock
just one floor you've identified now two
major flaws in that strategy yes the
point I'm trying to make is that the
doctrinal floor was the biggest by a
long way because if we'd if if we'd had
a flu pandemic we still would have had
the problem of no plan in place for
lockdown no prep for how to do one no
work on how best to lock down with the
least damage I I you know I understand
deeply the consequences of lockdown and
the negative consequences for many many
people many of which persist to this day
the problem that we faced was that the
consequence of not locking down was much
worse and we need to be able to be I
think John Edmonds is excellent in his
um in his evidence saying and Gus
O'Donnell saying we need to have a way
to calibrate as early as possible what
would the damage be of this if we don't
if you said I'm going to pause you there
the issue of lockdown is as you know
very well indeed something for module
two and we are concerned now with your
understanding pre-pandemic and what was
being done pre-pandemic may I ask you
please to focus on
this strategy document which sets out at
that time what the thinking was and I I
understand that but if I just may say Mr
Hancock
will you allow me please
in this forum
it is the point the question of course
the 2011 strategy
was never updated was it uh not the time
no it wasn't no
indeed the work stream which was due to
be carried out but the pandemic flu
Readiness board to update that strategy
was itself paused was it not
as I understand it yes yes
that there's been ample evidence to show
that the work was not done to update
this
document this strategy but because of
the diversion of resources to
the necessary preparations for a No Deal
EU exit is that that is correct yes all
right
were you told Secretary of State when
you were secretary of state that
the strategy was regarded as
inaccurate
and not up to date no
not that I'm aware not that I recall on
the contrary we were told that we were
the best one of the best places in terms
of preparation
are you surprised now that you were not
informed that the
strategy was deemed to be and I quote a
document from your own Department out of
date unfit for purpose I was not aware
of that note
by July of 2019
an arm's length body I suppose one would
call it or a stakeholder Public Health
England
what was stating in its own minutes that
there had been no word from the dhsc on
the dhsc's pandemic strategy so they
were concerned
that they'd heard nothing from your
department in relation to the updating
of this strategy
because it was obviously a matter of
very real concern
I don't recall that ever being raised
with me and it highlights the problem of
not having a body that was focused only
on preparing to defend us against a
pandemic since the health Protection
Agency was abolished in 2012 and that
was one of the reasons behind the
organizational change I brought in later
all right
the pandemic influence of preparedness
board was another important part of the
Department's work was yes
what was its main function as you saw it
well it was a
um official level board whose job
effectively was to put into place the
conclusions of sickness and to make sure
that we were as well prepared as
possible
when you became Secretary of State
presumably you were informed of the
outcome of exercise cygnus and of the
fact that the then Prime Ministers may
had ordered the setting up of the
pandemic flu Readiness board yes to put
those recommendations into into place
yes I found that reassuring I'd been
reassured that essentially everything
was in hand because there was a a
structure a resourced structure to make
it happen
as it happens Mr Hancock
many of the work streams which the
pandemic flu Readiness board planned to
carry out were for reasons we've we've
discussed paused or ceased altogether
so when you were Secretary of State
to what extent were you informed that
the recommendations from exercise cygnus
about which you had been told were not
in fact being implemented
I don't know the answer to that question
I I take full responsibility for the
facts that in the face of brexit and the
threats that are disorganized brexit
could do
um we took
um the resources were moved across the
department
to focus on that threat including away
from pandemic preparedness planning this
was proposed to me
by the permanent secretary and the CMO
and I signed it off I regarded the
Secretary of State's job not to run the
department in terms of resource
allocation but to set the direction but
I take this but I I signed off that
decision
the thing that the thing is that you
face a lot of risks and threats
look secret Miss tanko why didn't you
say to your civil servants
this was a major exercise in the United
Kingdom's pandemic influenza
preparedness
it was one of the largest command post
exercises ever held
it made a number of
important recommendations 22 in fact in
all yeah
across the whole Board of the United
Kingdom's plans and capabilities
and by June 2020 after the pandemic had
struck of course
the dhsc
acknowledged that of the 22
recommendations eight had been fully
addressed six have been partially
addressed and worked to address eight
more
was still ongoing
how could that have been missed how
could those recommendations not have
been put into place
between
July 18 when you took that post
and 2020 when the chickens came home to
roost well the answer to that question
there's two ways of answering that
question the first is that as a
secretary of state you have a limited
set of resources and you have to make
sure that those resources are targeted
at the threats that you face and one of
those risks was a disorganized brexit
and it was incumbent on the department
to make sure that we were as well
prepared for that as possible and the
second way of answering the same
question is that it isn't really about
the the numbers of recommendations from
cygnus it's about what those
recommendations were and the problem
with sickness is it did not spot the
central problem in pandemic planning so
I'm having looked through those
recommendations that were not put in
place I'm not sure they would have
helped much when the chickens as you say
came home to roost because we did
because cygnus did not recommend that we
should be prepared to stop the spread of
a pandemic it made all sorts of
recommendations for how to deal with the
worst case scenario happening and the
and and therefore
I I am not at all convinced that we
would have been much better place to
face this pandemic had all of those
recommendations been put into place
um because because there was a much
bigger error
all right
but those exercises take place for a
good reason do they not yes but they
still it still didn't spot the main
problem
are they important matters Mr Hancock of
course and were recommendations made a
number of them as a result of that
exercise yes and did your department
fail to implement all those records I'm
not denying any of that I'm explaining
firstly the different pressures that you
have on resources and uh and and brexit
was real
um and a uh a pressure and I'm also
explaining the consequences of those
decisions and I'm I'm trying to
articulate that there was a much bigger
problem that we must and and the central
lesson that I think we need to learn
well we'll come to that in a moment the
report into exercise cygnus was not
published was it in July 17 when it
reported no
um could we have please five seven five
one four
and page two
you were asked in May of 2020 of course
after the pandemic had struck
whether or not you agreed that the
report into exercise cygnus from July 17
should be published yes we can see the
top left hand
corner of the page to number two SOS
Secretary of State yes
and if you could scroll back out please
the issue is
the issue identified in the submission
was that a number of public
parliamentary and legal requests for
release of the report of exercise cygnus
have been received
it was a pandemic influencer
preparedness exercise Paradise in 2016.
to date we've declined to release this
report based on a balanced assessment of
the public interest and and you're
invited in fact to agree that the time
had come for the publication of that
report yes
do you know why in general terms the
report
why the decision was taken in July 17
not to publish the report and and why
this only came to you for a decision in
May 2020
I have no idea about the 2017 decision I
know why it came to me for a decision in
2020 and that's because people were
understandably asking to see it and I
supported publication
can we have a look please at page four
paragraphs eight and ten
thank you
paragraph eight some projects had to be
rescheduled in 2018 and 19 due to
competing priorities in civil
contingencies
is that a partly concealed reference to
the fact that work streams had to be
stopped to deal with the necessary
preparations for a no-deal EU exit yes
there will also have been there were
other civil contingencies for instance
there was a crisis of human body parts
being left in hospital car parks that
the Civil contingencies team had to deal
with
um there were various other civil
contingencies in that period but it so
it is not purely a euphemism for for
brexit it is a an accurate description
of the pressures on the Civil contingent
on the team Mr Hancock this is a
document
which is solely concerned with the
publication of the report and exercise
cygnus which was itself only concerned
with emergency preparedness for pandemic
influenza yes
the reference to some projects in
paragraph 8 yes is only a reference
isn't it to the projects which came from
exercise cygnus that's correct yes and
the only reason that those projects were
rescheduled
by virtue of decisions of the pandemic
influenza preparedness program board the
pandemic flu Readiness board and your
own Department
was because the the diversion of
resources to deal with the No Deal EU
exit
um I'm explaining that the competing
priorities in civil contingencies of
course included that but there are also
other competing priorities the the
context I'm trying to set explain for
all of this is that in health you have a
certain amount of resources and you have
a very broad set of risks and whilst
it's vital that this inquiry uses
hindsight to learn the lessons we didn't
have that at the time and we didn't know
that a pandemic was about to strike
could we have please the bottom of page
five
Communications and public confidence
whilst this would not be a consideration
for Freedom of Information purposes this
isn't the context of courses of deciding
whether the report should be published
it is if you're considering going beyond
your legal duties advice on
Communications is below
mitigation that is to say mitigation of
Damage Done in the public sphere by
virtue of the communications you should
note that while work is ongoing there
are no major gaps in our implementation
of the lessons from cygnus
that wasn't quite right was it
um I think that the
um officials writing this document have
used the word major
to explain that the central
recommendations from cygnus
um were implemented for instance cygnus
recommended that we have a draft legal
bill ready to go and that proved to be
incredibly important in the early
response to the pandemic and I made the
point earlier that
um the inquiry will be wrong to conclude
that because not every lesson from
cygnus had been implemented that had
every lesson been implemented the
response would have been that much
better because cygnus was flawed in its
Central assumption about how best to
respond to a to a pandemic
so you've referred Mr Hancock then to
one particular work stream which was the
drawing up of a draft
pandemic Bill yes
to justify your answer that there were
no major gaps in our implementation of
the lessons from cygnus
what other work streams were completed
as far as you're aware in addition to
the drafting of a bill
um were completed well I don't have that
paperwork to hand but I'd be very happy
to uh to supply it
page seven please
paragraph 15
on the 7th of May the Guardian newspaper
published the full report on its website
with personal information redacted this
was alongside an article highlighting
that there was no evidence
recommendations from the report around
social care preparedness had been acted
on
that was right wasn't it yes one of the
areas the important work streams which
had not been concluded or even in part
developed was
to do with the capacity of the adult
social care sector to be able to deal
with
that's not quite right the demands of a
pandemic that as part of the work
ongoing when I was Secretary of State
preparedness in Social care
was one of those work streams yes
work was done wasn't it in order to try
to see whether or not
the department could make itself better
informed as to the sheer number of
people in the adult yes social care
sector
work was done on producing some policy
papers that would be of use to local
authorities who of course are primary
responsible for the adult social care
sector
but no work was done was it in relation
to Preparing the individual care homes
for the necessary surge in numbers
attendant upon a pandemic
work was done
in the first two areas you you mentioned
this report the article was inaccurate
however
the
responsibility
for ensuring preparedness in Social care
formally fell to local authorities
and there was work required of local
authorities to put in place pandemic
preparedness plans when the pandemic
struck and I was told that local
authorities were required to have
Pandemic preparedness plans I asked to
see them
and my my Minister for social care uh
Helen waitley found that there were only
two
at which she saw and reported to me them
to be wholly inadequate
one of the central challenges in Social
care is that whilst I have the title
Secretary of State for Health and Social
care
the response primary responsibility
legal responsibility contractual
responsibility for social care Falls to
local councils in a national crisis this
is a very significant problem because as
I put it in my witness statement we I
did I had the title I was accountable
but I didn't have the levers to act
and we didn't even have the data and
this is the work that was ongoing before
the pandemic which is why this statement
here from the guardian reported from the
guardian is inaccurate
um there was work I'm going to try to
find out even the basics of the
provision of social care for instance
how many
Care Homes are operating right now in
the UK that was a fact that we did not
know at that time and I'm glad to say
now there's far better data but that was
that was one of the work streams and it
you know it's it it it it was it was
very important and that work continued
some work was done by the department to
make itself better informed
particular
in relation to the numbers of persons in
Care Homes and the working Arrangements
in the adult social care sector
but the vital work
directly concerned with the preparation
of those Care Homes
which was part of the work stream
meant to be done by the pandemic flu
Readiness board was not done was it
that's not those two plans
were all that there was on the local
Authority side
and The Surge planning in relation to
the adult social care sector fell far
behind that done for the NHS did it not
that work
nevertheless was done
um and being done and it is it is a in
fact this discussion is an example of
the challenge of why it's so hard
for policy in Social care when the
accountability Falls understandably to
the Secretary of State
but in this case
pandemic preparedness was a legal
responsibility at the local level and
whilst we at the health department could
require that the money for social care
from central government goes through a
different department
um and so the requirement to produce
those
um plans felt at local authorities and
they were in very large part uh not
concluded before the pandemic struck and
that that is that is a major problem
with how social cares run in this
country
the obligation to get ready did not rest
solely on the local Authority did it
the obligation for the policy rested
with me the obligation for delivery uh
are in Social care rests with local
authorities they're the ones who
contract individual Care Homes the
Department of Health and Social care
understood
that an important line of work a work
stream
to be carried out by the pandemic free
Readiness board and the pandemic
influenza preparedness program board
was ensuring that the adult social care
sector was ready in terms of plans
what would they do in the event of a
pandemic and surge capacity how would
they physically cope
with the impact of a catastrophic
pandemic yeah and deliver obligations on
the Department of Health and Social care
and they were not completed were they
they were to be delivered through local
authorities which proved extremely
difficult and that is a structural
problem with how social care has been
organized in this country since 1948.
that may be so Mr Hancock but it was a
responsibility that the Department of
Health and Social scale was aware of
otherwise it wouldn't have directed that
these work streams be drawn up at all
absolutely right absolutely the NSC thrc
the National Security Council threats
has its resilience and contingencies
committee was the committee to which you
referred earlier the committee chaired
by the then prime minister who had
ordered the setting up of the pandemic
flu Readiness board yes
the terms of reference for that board
required the Secretary of State for
health
to report progress to the National
Security Council thrc committee on the
work of the pandemic flu Readiness board
could we have please 22743
I think if we're going to a slightly
different topic Keith I think probably
if that's convenient for you yes indeed
we take regular breaks because we have a
brave sonographer who coaches us all but
very well I shall return at
um 25 past
a half past podcast
okay
Mr Hancock I was about to put you the
terms of reference for the pandemic flu
Readiness board they are two two seven
four three
page one please
the first paragraph on page one
to the setting up of the board
and refers back to that meeting
about which you give evidence earlier
the NSC thrc
meeting in February 17.
the board
and the discussion reaffirmed the
government's commitment to ensuring the
UK was prepared to manage the health
effects of severe pandemic influenza as
defined by the reasonable worst case
scenario and The Wider consequences
since the demise of the pandemic flu
implementation group there has been no
dedicated group with responsibility for
preparations for the cross-governed
impacts of pandemic influenza
this time got the pandemic flu Readiness
board was co-chaired of course by
your then department dhsc and the
cabinet office
but it was the
the only board which provided oversight
for a program which will deliver the
plans and capabilities to manage The
Wider consequences of pandemic influenza
and then on page two please
paragraphs five and six
roles and responsibilities of members
the membership of the board is intended
to reflect the breadth of the
government's responsibility for the
potential consequences of an influenza
pandemic on the nation members of the
board will represent the interests of
their Department
and then at six the board will report
progress to NSC thrc that's the
committee the ministerial committee
which set up the board via the Secretary
of State for health and Minister for the
cabinet office
will receive regular progress updates in
parallel
it is obvious that
the Department of Health and the cabin
office regarded it as essential that the
work been done by this sole
cross-government body the only body
dealing with
cross-government pandemic influenza
preparedness
provide regular updates to the
ministerial committee which set it up
there were two
NSC thrc that's the overarching
committee
to such
committee meetings attended by officials
how many of those overarching meetings
NSC thrc meetings did you go to
in order to inform them of those regular
progress updates
personally personally none that I can
remember I attended the National
Security
Council from time to time when the
agenda included areas that I was
responsible for I was not a standing
attendee but I don't recall ever being
asked to attend to report on this
did you know of the existence of the NSC
thrc the minister overarching
ministerial committee to which you were
expected to report yes I attended it
that's essentially the National Security
Council no the NSC thrc the threats
hazards resilience and contingencies
committee yes that's a subcommittee that
one is the subcommittee of the National
Security Council how many of those
subcommittee meetings did you attend I
can't recall did you attend any
uh it I may well have attended none but
I can't recall have you seen any piece
of paper that suggests you did attend
nope
why not I have no idea because the
department for health was not
responsible for the agenda of that
uh
that committee or indeed The Wider
National Security Council the attendance
of
ministers in the Department of Health
was
determined by whether they were invited
Mr Hancock
your own Department's committee the
board which you co-chaired with the
cabin office
knew full well that you were expected to
report to the NSC thrc with updates on
the board's work
can you think of any reason why you
didn't attend those meetings why you
weren't told about the meetings why you
weren't informed of the expectation that
you attend those meetings
the only explanation I can give is that
the
team faced a significant number of
different threats and challenges and
they chose during the relatively short
period Irish Secretary of State before
the pandemic struck
to focus on other
issues that they felt to be appropriate
I mean
my experience in government both as
Secretary of State for Health and Social
care and before was was that the
officials who
handle and are responsible for
the National Security Council and its
subcommittees are exceptionally diligent
extremely hard working and have the
highest integrity and that goes for all
of the officials I work for in the
department I worked with in the
department for health and and social
care and all I can say is they would
have known and it would have been
incumbent on them to consider all
threats and make decisions as to the
agenda according to what's necessary may
we have please
180188 this is a
a document
relating to
the
officials subcommittee okay of the NSC
thrc in fact the NSC thrco meeting o for
officials yeah and it's dated the 19th
of December 2018 so after you took
office in July 18.
if we could go to page three
paragraph two
EU exit planning the cabinet office
updated members on their civil
contingencies Secretariat prioritization
work in the lead up to EU exit they plan
to move into the operational mode of EU
exit planning in early January
CCS stressed the capacity will may be
maintained to continue normal
preparedness activities and ensuring
that part two of the CCA is refined if
required
in discussion members raise the
following points
as part of normal preparedness
activities would continuity of Crisis
management continue the
advise it will be maintained but some
elements will be prioritized
some departments still wish to provide
feedback and then there was a debate
about would hostiles state
activity exercises exercises continue
the chair summarized that officials
should continue to brief ministers on
what level of business as usual
activities departmental responsibilities
could continue following a move to the
operational mode of EU exit planning
so
in the Autumn of the winter of 2018
over a year before the pandemic struck
at this officials meeting of the
National Security Council thrc committee
there was debate
about the fact that the EU exit planning
was starting to have an impact or would
be likely to start to have an impact on
preparedness planning
because of the prioritization of work
and there's a clear reference there to
ministers being briefed
as to what levels of business as usual
activities would continue
notwithstanding the necessary
prioritization of work towards a No Deal
EU exit
when were you briefed in the autumn and
winter of 2018 as to
what was coming
well I was of course aware that brexit
was a significant part of the national
debate and the in the department we
needed to be prepared for it
and
the so that briefing was
ongoing
um and as we discussed earlier
there was a moment at which we had to
move resources on to prepare for
um that in the summer I think of 2019
um and
um we did that within the department the
plans to do that were drawn up by the by
the team and I signed them off but I
returned to my broader point which is
the professionalism and diligence with
which the Civil Service team
looked at all of the different
challenges and threats that were faced
was exemplary
could we have 57430 please this is a
memo from within your department
to Professor sir Chris witty the current
CMO of course who you you know very well
and I think he was a former departmental
scientific advisory correct the
department
stated the 27th of March 2019.
and it concerns the reallocation of work
paragraph one two secretary you are
aware that following reorganization and
re-prioritization of dhsc work due to EU
exit No Deal planning
pan flu preparedness and high
consequence infectious disease policy
has moved to your portfolio of
responsibilities on a temporary basis
and then a page three a paragraph three
exco
what is xcode that's the executive
committee of the department for Health
and Social Care chaired by the permanent
secretary that's the committee that
effectively runs the department on an
executive basis but subject to the
supervisory role of the departmental
board which you referred earlier about
yes and of course
um working two ministerial priorities
and decisions
exco agreed that the department would
need to do less work in some areas in
order to free up resource for EU exit
preparations as a result Emma Reed and
Clara Swinson agreed a range of work
related to pan flu and hcid that would
be scaled back or paused before this
policy area transferred across to you
Annex a
summarizes the work areas that are
continuing and those of which are on
hold
so this paragraph makes plain that at
the highest level in your department
subject only to the supervisory review
of the board and yourself
not just that there was a prioritization
across government
in favor of EU exit work but that a
range of work related to pan flu and
hcid would be scaled back or paused
that was a policy decision of
great significance was it no
it was a policy decision
I would query whether it had great
significance as you can see from the
numbers on this page the numbers of
people working in this area the numbers
of move movement is small
and my second observation is that this
work
was following a wrong the wrong approach
and I'm not sure it would have been any
use in the pandemic and that's my
judgment from having been the man in the
you know the person in the in the hot
seat when the pandemic struck
do you recall that debate before xco
and yes I recall the debate because I
discussed it with the permanent
secretary because whilst he was
responsible for the running of the
department he of course would then check
with me that I was content with the
proposals that he put together and there
were many other areas of work that had
to be stopped in order to prepare for
brexit as well I mean this wasn't the
only area there were a whole series of
them
so you were aware and you agreed that a
range of work relating to pan flu and
hcid would have to be scaled back or
paused
yes and I I wasn't enthusiastic about it
but I signed it off and the reason that
I signed off that overall reshaping of
the department is because we had a very
real and material threat should a
disorganized brexit happen that we
needed to be prepared for and it comes
back to the point about context that
there are many many bad things you have
to prepare for when you're of the in the
health department
moving forward eight months to the eve
of the pandemic in November 2019 23089
[Music]
the minutes for the pandemic flu
Readiness board
the pandemic flu Readiness board has not
met since November 18 due to
re-prioritization in 2019 to plan for
potential No Deal EU exit
so the sole cross government body set up
by direction of the Prime Minister
did not meet
at all did it
between November 2018 and the 27th of
November 2019.
that's what this paper says
were you aware Mr Hancock
that for a whole year the board did not
even meet I do not recall being aware of
that note
but also I but I do know that work under
the board's guidance continued because I
was engaged in some of the workers we've
discussed
um especially but not only on vaccine
manufacturing page five paragraph seven
and eight
thank you
the pfrb had committed to meet every six
to eight weeks until the key outputs of
the work program were delivered
proposed that in 2020 it meets every
three months this will ensure the
progress can be communicated to key
planning partners
through updated documentation where
appropriate
so it was understood wasn't it that
although it had committed to meet every
six to eight weeks
failure to meet for a whole year fell
very far short of what it had apparently
committed itself to doing that's what I
understand too from reading these papers
yeah
NH na it says nhst t-h-r-c it should be
NSC thrc under the pfrb's current
governance Arrangements the board
reports on progress to the NSC thrc the
board which you the
subcommittee which you cannot recall
attending due to EU exit pressures NSC
thrc were not updated at the end of year
two March 19.
so it didn't not just not meet
it wasn't even updated at the end of
year 2 March 2019 the second full year
of its operations
was it
evidently from reading these papers I
wasn't aware of these papers at the time
and then of course after the pandemic
struck inq 23114
on the 15th of January 2020
pandemic influenza Readiness board works
stream updates last updated the 15th of
January 2020
the healthcare work stream progress has
slowed for a number of reasons
two Community Care
progress on the Community Health Care
site has slowed for a number of reasons
and then over the page please
or further down the page
excess deaths that was one of the work
streams on which work was completed
wasn't it
you referred earlier in your evidence to
the fact that you were aware that was a
work streamer which worked was done it
work was done I'm not sure that it was
completed because we had to do further
work on it when the pandemic struck
that's why I was pausing to try to
recollect
and express that correctly over the page
sector resilience there's been no
further work on this work stream a
statements of preparedness are finalized
it was agreed that the sharing of the
business checklist should be paused as a
result of the need to communicate other
risks including EU exit what is sector
resilience Mr Hancock well sector
resilience is ensuring that there is
resilience especially of Supply chains
in this case pharmaceutical in
particular but also non-pharmaceutical
Goods required for Health and Social
care sector
Health and Social care sectors
within the department that would have
been the purview yes
um cross-cutting enablers all England
Clauses and supporting documentation
complete including explanatory note and
assessment of impact is that a reference
to the drafting of the bill to which you
made reference earlier
um the um
it's a
it appears so that's what four nations
bill was used as the shorthand yes
there's a reference to the pauses and
supporting documentation so that appears
to be rat appears so on the previous one
on number four of course the work that
was intended to be prepared for a no
deal brexit was itself
important incredibly important when it
came to the pandemic so this paper
doesn't quite capture
capture it it captures the planning and
uh is that a reference to the fact that
work was done on securing and
safeguarding medicinal Supply chains
correct to deal with a No Deal EU exit
yes but that issue of Supply chains Mr
Hancock
was just one wasn't it
of a very much larger number of areas in
which work was required across the
health sector and the adult social care
sector
not unimportant
but it was just one of the areas wasn't
it where work was required I wouldn't
put it like that and if I may the way
I'd say it is that
the work done for a No Deal brexit on
Supply chains for medicines
was the difference between running out
of medicines in the peak of the pandemic
and not running out
we came extremely close within hours of
running out of medicines for intensive
care during the pandemic it wasn't
widely reported at the time
and I think the only reason that we
didn't run out is because of the work
that Steve Oldfield and his team did
which they did during 2019 in
preparation for a No Deal brexit
but became
extremely useful in Saving Lives
during the pandemic at the point at
which the pandemic struck because of the
No Deal brexit work we knew not more
about the pharmaceutical supply chain in
the UK than at any time in history and
we had relationships with the
pharmaceutical suppliers and the data to
know exactly who had what available and
where and the extent of that information
was the difference between running out
and not running out of of drugs in
intensive care in the pandemic now that
of course wasn't the intention of the
work but it was the consequence of the
work so when it comes to the question of
the overall impact of brexit absolutely
the paperwork is very clear that some of
the preparation work was stopped and a
small number of people were moved off
that work
on the other hand we were better
prepared in terms of
Supply chains who knows the overall
impact and which of those balances in
the scales is greater I'm I'm afraid
it's impossible to know
Mr Hancock
whilst
that may well be right that there was
valuable work done in an important area
of preparation namely medicinal Supply
chains
this chart and particular Row 4 sector
resilience makes plain
that across the swathe of the healthcare
and social adult social care sectors
important other areas of work of which
there were many more than the single
issue of medicinal Supply chains were
paused or interrupted that is the point
isn't it and that is one point I agree
and and a further but the further point
is of significance which is the most
significant and it's impossible to know
whether one was more significant than
the other than the others
whether the reduction in the number of
people that is demonstrated by the
paperwork on
um pandemic preparedness whether the
impact the negative impact of that is
outweighed or is not outweighed by the
positive impact of the supply chain
planning as I said the number of
um uh activities is not as important as
their consequence and because operation
sickness which was guiding this work
itself was flawed in conception I'm not
uh convinced that there would have been
that much help even if all of these um
uh things were done of course it would
have been better if they had but I
simply have no idea how helpful they
would have been
were you told the secretary of state
that the pfrb had not met for a year and
that as this document shows by January
of 2020
in a number of important areas work had
paused
um I was aware that some work had paused
I don't recall being aware that the
board hadn't met
there was another board the pandemic
influenza preparedness board again to
which you've referred earlier
do you recall that it was in the the
nature of that board's work to prepare
annually a risk register setting out in
the field of
influenza preparedness what the greatest
risks were do you recall that I don't I
don't recall that but I'm not surprised
all right but one from one year to
another I doubt it would have changed
much and it was again the central
failing of that sort of risk register
was not to learn the lessons from MERS
and SARS as has been discussed and as
I've made
um clear in my submission not to have
the right plan to deal with a pandemic
would you agree that in 2016 the risk
register for that Central dhsc LED board
showed a risk that supplies of face
masks respirators and gloves could be
below the optimum requirement in the
event of a pandemic
and that the Health and Social Care
Systems would be unable to cope with an
extreme surge in demand for services in
the event of a pandemic I wasn't aware
of that no that in 2017 the following
year
countermeasures were still a risk issue
the supply of face masks respirators and
gloves could be below the Autumn
requirement and an extreme surge in the
NHS and social care system was still an
identified risk that's 2017. yes if I
may say so my my recollection was being
reassured that we had a huge stockpile
of PPE of course it's possible to write
that it may be below the optimum because
the optimum may be an absolutely
enormous quantity which is exactly what
we needed so it can be perfectly true to
say it's below the optimum and at the
same time reassure that it's huge
the Health and Social care system may be
unable to cope with an extreme surge in
demand that was an identified risk in
the PIP risk register in 2017.
and by 2018 the 24th of September
the following risks were still being
identified
issues with face masks respirators
gloves below the optimum requirement
plans for the surge that would be
required in the Health and Social Care
Systems were not fully tested there was
a risk in relation to the Health and
Social Care Systems being unable to cope
in the event of a pandemic remains
in the event of a pandemic and that risk
remains so
for two and a half years those risks
having been identified
by the PIP board were not mitigated by
virtue of being addressed they remained
did they not they certainly did and we
had to deal with them when they
materialized indeed but that is a board
and a program which was led by your
department so the next question Mr
hankorg is how can that have been
allowed to happen with the inevitable
consequence Mr Hancock that you yourself
of course had to deal with the
consequences of those risks not be
mitigated when you
yes so that was the pandemic in January
2020 absolutely the inability to get the
PPE out fast enough was a very
significant problem one recommendation I
have for the future is that every Health
and Social care setting should be
required to have its own stockpile of
PPE and that should be paid for by the
by this by the government because in the
early days getting it out fast enough
when there was a sudden increase in
demand just as explained there that was
incredibly difficult so yes I totally
accept that
under a pip paper
a pandemic influenza preparedness
program board paper dated
October 19 or the eve of the pandemic
may we have 23070
page one paragraph one
the paper reminded the board of the pan
flu program re-prioritization that took
place at the end of 2018 and set out
progress made on those areas of work
that continued and new priorities that
arose
a paragraph three
there's a reference to an Annex
perhaps we could have a look at that
Annex please
go back up please to the start of the
annex thank you
thank you Annex a pan flu program
reproditization at the end of 2018 work
areas pan flu build that's a reference
to the draft Bill to which you referred
permanent secretary meetings on pan flu
continue perm secretary written updates
on pan flu continue quarterly Finance
meetings continue
moral and ethical Advisory Group
membership and recruitment stop UK
pandemic influenza strategy refresh stop
Healthcare search largely compete D.A
The Vault Administration engagement to
develop plans outstanding stopped
adult social care largely complete for
the pandemic flu Readiness board but CMO
actions outstanding stop
pfrb paper on the updating the NSC stop
Toms stop
Benchmark NHS Readiness internationally
stop engagement in the clinical
encounter measures board stop and so on
yeah
were you told
of the
extent to nature of the stock categories
well
um I'm I'm absolutely accountable for it
because I'm accountable for everything
happened in the department
um I would also though ask you to
consider each of these in detail because
it comes to the point we discussed
earlier on significance
for instance the moral and ethical
Advisory Group existed it had membership
when the pandemic struck so further
membership and recruitment was
not a consideration that would have made
a material difference to planning for
the for the pandemic the influencer
strategy refresh that was a 2011
document it would that would only have
been significant if that refresh had
completely changed the strategy that the
entire Western world was following that
was regarded as by The Who as uh as Best
in Class may I pause you that is that
the 2011 strategy approach in your
witness statement you state that for the
purposes of pandemic planning was
woefully woefully inadequate and I don't
think a refresh would have changed that
because all of the independent external
advice the World Health Organization
advice indeed the international Health
regulations stated that we should not
have lockdowns in fact in 2017 document
it said the evidence is not strong
enough to Warrant advocating legislative
restrictions this is where I I'm I need
to add to what I've written in my
written statement because I thought at
the time it was simply an oversight not
to consider lockdowns actually it was an
explicit decision the London resilience
partnership published document May 2018
and I quote it will not be possible to
Halt the spread of a new pandemic that
was the attitude it was the doctrine and
it was wrong so that refresh would have
made very little difference Healthcare
surge is lot was largely complete the
final action there is on involvement of
the DA's since Healthcare is devolved
that would have been a a a not been a
terribly important area adult social
care largely complete I'm not exactly
sure what the CMO action is outstanding
are
um my point is about materiality may I
just pause you there to ask you some
more questions about you I've got social
care yes you raise it yes in your
statement you refer to the fact that one
of the major problems with
the department supervision of the adult
social Care Center was
was the lack of policy levers yes which
would enable the department to ensure
pandemic preparedness absolutely social
care yes and as you said earlier but
that's not what this is refacting well I
want to ask you whether or not you can
say that the adult social care sector
was well prepared for a pandemic when
the department had no means of
finding out whether or not they had the
right plans in place but the local
authorities had planned sufficiently let
alone how many numbers were in the care
sector no it was terrible the department
had no visibility of whether or not the
health adult social care sector was
prepared at all
but it wasn't within your ability
that's not my contention my contention
is this action here would not have
solved that the CMO could not have
solved the problems in terms of
oversight of the adult social care uh
sectors it was much bigger than that
what was the name of your department
that I've come I've already talked about
this it was it's the Department of
Health and Social care and yet the legal
responsibilities are with local
authorities and we had a program a
separate program work underway that did
not stop because of brexit planning that
was accelerated by the new prime
minister in summer 2019 of Reform of
adult social care we had ongoing work to
get better data that was that was
continued in this uh in this process
adult social care desperately needs
reform it needs more support it needs
more resilience and I feel that very
strongly as does the current chancellor
exchequer who has been clear about that
not only when he was in my job but in
his current job my point and my
contention is that this whatever the CMO
actions outstanding were here they would
not have solved the huge challenges of
adult social care in this country which
requires
significant Improvement and work
by January 20
did the department have in place
the department of social care having
place
a single coherent plan to identify
vulnerable service users across the
country that is to say how many people
are in the care sector
no did it have a central plan for the
sharing of data between private and
public care providers and emergency
responders in order to be able to better
prepare them all for a pandemic
something along those lines was being
developed but it was definitely not in
place was there a single National
guidance for pandemic preparedness in
the adult social care sector the
guidance for pandemic preparedness went
through local authorities and so there
was not a single one no did all the lrf
the local resilience forums have plans
in place on the local Authority level
for dealing with the impact of a
catastrophic catastrophic pandemic on
the elderly no they were required to and
as far as I'm aware only two had done
the work was the Department of Health
and Social care able to verify the
extent of the pandemic preparedness
planning that was being done by local
authorities no we didn't have the policy
levers to do so despite having the name
social care in the title did the
department of social care put into place
a National Standard by which the plans
from the local Authority could be gauged
nope
in relation to those local resilience
forums
did the department prepare in fact a
pandemic flu standard
at the latter end of 2019 which for the
very first time obliged local resilience
forums to compare their plans against a
national standard for
influenza pandemic planning well
um yes is the answer it is and the and I
suppose what that demonstrates because
that came into place late in 2019. yes
it is my central contention in this area
which is that the system for how we run
adult social care is flawed there was
work on going to try to resolve it
including work directly related to
pandemic planning but it was in nowhere
near good enough shape and it meant that
as the as the person trying to solve
this problem with a disease that
self-evidently impacted on older people
most we were in an incredibly difficult
position to do so when the pandemic
struck and despite the enormous hard
work of everybody in that sector and in
the department in relation to adult
social care it was very very difficult
early on and that's been in part because
this planning was on going but the
systems in this country for managing
adult social care are not good enough
and uh that that that reform that reform
work was underway but it still hasn't
been completed
so drawing some of these threads
together please Mr Hancock
would you accept the following
propositions
firstly
there was a long-standing bias within
the Department of Health and Social care
as the risk owner of the
pandemic influenza risk and as the
author of that strategy which you
described as woefully inadequate
in favor of influenza a failure
to pay sufficient regard to the risk
admittedly a lesser risk of another
different catastrophic hcid
it would have been better yes if it if
the plans had been for a generic
respiratory
disease because what matters is the
characteristic of the novel virus indeed
proposition 2 there was a failure to
think through properly the risks of a
non-influenza pandemic
due to the inherent unpredictability
of viral respiratory pathogens and their
characteristics as you say transmission
rate high or stuttering incubation
period long or short viral loads great
or less
whether
viruses congregate in the upper or lower
respiratory tract
whatever they may have been
because those other characteristics were
simply not thought about enough
the real risk of an hcid with
catastrophic consequences was not
adequately thought about either
I wouldn't put it like that and I think
there's an irony here
the irony is that one of the major
problems we had early on which I'm sure
we'll come to an M2 was the fact that
covid-19 has asymptomatic transmission
it's the first known coronavirus that
affects humans that can be transmitted
asymptomatically
and the who assumption was that this
wasn't possible until April 2020.
um there's a really important reason I'm
saying this a flu plan assumes
asymptomatic transmission indeed there
are some ways in which the flu plan was
in fact more appropriate as a planning
document
than a generic
document or indeed a document that had
been written to consider the impact of
one of the then known coronaviruses
because that plan a coronavirus pandemic
plan would have assumed no asymptomatic
transmission so this is underpins my
point that of course it would have been
better to plan for a generic you know
respiratory disease X and that is what
we should do in future however planning
for the planning for flu did have some
benefits
and it brings me back to my central
contention that whilst this was an error
it was in no way the biggest error and
it's not just that there were two errors
in the core plan you know flew rather
than coronavirus and wrong Doctrine the
era of the flawed Doctrine was
significantly bigger than the era of
targeting a flu rather than a
coronavirus pandemic all right
well I I don't need to trouble you about
degrees of failure will come on to
identifying the the various propositions
yeah
the third issue is one you've just
touched upon which is that that approach
in the risk assessment was cause
agnostic it simply failed to identify a
sufficiently broad range of scenarios
and as you know the risk assessment
process has been Rewritten
thanks in the main tour report from the
Royal Academy of engineering yes to make
that flame yes and there's an irony
there as well which is that we were
dealing with a live Ebola epidemic with
the Potential Threat that would come to
this country as a pandemic
um and yet at the same time the
paperwork was all focused on a flu
pandemic yes so in PR the theory written
down in these strategies was actually
not what was playing out in the
day-to-day practice of
infectious disease management that we
were undertaking as a department and
that phe was undertaking
Bangkok it's not just a question of
Ireland is it these failings materially
hampered the United Kingdom's ability to
prevent death the central failing that
that hampered the UK's response common
with the rest of the western world was
the refusal and the explicit
the explicit decision that it would not
be possible to Halt the spread of a new
pandemic that is wrong and that is at
the center of the failure of preparation
I know that because I was the person
responsible as the category one
responder when this pandemic struck and
all of the other considerations are are
small important but small compared to
the Colossal scale of failure it
in the assumption that it will not be
possible and the lack of ambition in the
assumption that you can't stop the
spread of a disease we can you know
imagine if this disease had had
tragically killed children as much as it
did old people and maybe it transmitted
twice as easily as covid
would it then be possible to stop this
whole to Halt the spread of course it
would we would do whatever it took and
that's where we got to but it it but we
got there far far too slowly because
none of the preparation included any
thinking around that and that is my
fourth proposition it's the one that
finds
a place at the front of your witness
statement
it is that
there was a failure
a complete systemic failure to think
about how to prevent catastrophic
consequences
arising at all as opposed to how to
manage catastrophic consequences which
were assumed to result I couldn't agree
more and it's an absolute tragedy number
five
there was an Associated failure to think
about countermeasures because of course
flu has a shorter incubation period it
is symptomatic there are antivirals
there are vaccines available
there was therefore a failure
to think about in the way that other
countries particularly in the Far East
had done
countermeasures such as
mandatory quarantines yes shielding yeah
social restrictions yes border controls
yes there was as you say a complete lack
of imagination yes I had to overrule the
initial advice not to quarantine people
being brought back from Wuhan I mean
that is it's Madness and it was written
into the international Health
regulations that you shouldn't close
borders this was not a UK problem it was
a World Health Organization problem and
the World Health Organization of all
people should have learned the lessons
from MERS and SARS and so we had
diligent hard-working teams working on
this pandemic preparedness but there was
a absolutely Central doctrinal failure
in the response of the UK and almost
every other Western Country
and number six coming to the government
particularly
through the cabinet office and the dhsc
there was a failure to implement in a
general sense the recommendations from
the various earlier exercises because
the majority of them were simply not
implemented for good or ill by the time
the pandemic struck and actions and work
streams which were identified as being
necessary
in the fields of pandemic preparedness
were not carried through to fruition
while that is true my my evidence to you
is on materiality of what really
mattered when the pandemic struck and as
we saw when we went through that list on
the screen those
um work streams that were stopped I
couldn't identify any of them that would
have made a material impact had had
another Year's work been done on them we
just we went we got halfway through them
and are there on what I put that down to
is the team prioritizing within the
resources that were available to do the
things that really mattered and the
thing that was most useful to me when
the pandemic struck was making sure we
had a piece of legislation ready to get
onto the statute book now we you know
there's a lesson there as well which is
we need a new piece of legislation both
for civil contingencies and we need an
update to the 1984 Public Health act and
I'm very happy to give further evidence
on what's needed there but the my point
is that I think the team were working
very hard to try to do the things that
were the most material in terms of
preparation and what everybody missed in
the western world was that lockdowns
were going to be necessary and that's
why I'm stressing this point so much
because it is it is the most single most
important thing we can learn as a
country Mr steinko you've just said I
couldn't identify any of those work
streams that would have made material
impact
was not one of the work streams
the need to identify data
numbers
the planning for the number of people in
the adult social care sector would be
affected by a pandemic
and the planning for the required surge
capacity which would be required in the
event of a pandemic pandemic are you
saying those murder collection is that
data work continued as part of the adult
social care reform plans
did that work get completed by the time
of the pandemic it didn't get completed
but the work continued was a fully
developed plan for surge capacity in the
adult social care sector put into place
by the 1st of January 2020. a fully
developed plan no your question
originally to which I responded was what
the work being done but it hadn't been
completed no
there's a difference between doing work
and completing work there is a
difference between planning something
and not even completing the plan so that
the work can't be done
was the planning complete to allow the
surge capacity to be developed I'm very
happy to look further into the paperwork
and write to you on that point my point
I but my point was a
was a more strategic one about what
really matters in terms of protecting
lives in the future and that's why I'm
at so much pain to stress it
there were significant areas of
preparation overlooked or not progressed
you agree
absolutely
were the nation's preparations for a
pandemic of this nature good enough no
was there a serious insignificant
inadequacy of preparation for a pandemic
Health Emergency yes
preparing for this tier one risk of a
catastrophic Health Emergency was at the
core of your own Department's functions
would you agree yes
and therefore a secretary of state you
bore and you bear ministerial
responsibility for that calamitous State
of Affairs do you not
I bear responsibility for all the things
that happened not only in my department
but also the agencies that reported to
me as Secretary of State
you will no doubt have given a great
deal of thought and it's evident from
your evidence today Mr Hancock
as to how to make things better yes and
you've mentioned many of them today in
the course of evidence
are you aware of some of the matters
that sir Oliver let win spoke about when
he gave evidence
do you agree that there is now a need
for a formal system of training for
ministers and Senior civil servants in
civil contingencies yes there's an irony
here another one which is that I was in
the process of putting one in place with
the blavatnik school of government when
the pandemic struck and we stopped that
work because there were because the
pandemic became overwhelming is there a
case for a cabinet minister to be
appointed to be in Soul charge of eprr
yes across government and then the panda
then the responsibilities of lead
government departments would need to
report into that Minister who would then
act on behalf of the Prime Minister
that's effectively the job that Oliver
lettwin did when he was in office and
therefore there needs to be a head of
resilience at the Apex of a official
structure a civil servant who will then
report to that cabinet minister yes
there's one subtlety that's incredibly
important here which is that it would be
a mistake if such a structure took away
the sense and the feeling of
accountability for an individual
Department what you wouldn't want is the
department thinking oh well the cabinet
office has got that covered you need you
need the department to still feel that
it is accountable and held to account by
the cabinet offers rather than replaced
by the cabinet office which would be uh
sub-optimal so I'm not following what
he's suggesting would be different from
the present system Mr that you would
have as we had when Oliver letwin was in
post a minister responsible for
resilience across the board and for
challenging the different resilience
plans that came up and obviously that
will require an official structure
underneath her or him and um but the key
point is that needs to be like a red
team effort as has been discussed rather
than letting the Departments off the
hook for the areas which they're
responsible
do you have that Minister solely
responsible for his events I've heard
that cabinet office
folio on occasions
um
yes I think I'd I whether or not they
attended cabinet What mattered in
actually is in practice whether they had
the ear of the Prime Minister
you you could easily make it the person
who was in my old cabinet office job as
number two so long as they had a direct
line to the Prime Minister when it
mattered
is the now a case for an independent
perhaps statutory
resilience Academy or some such body to
to warn advise guide in relation to eprr
train organize exercises and make sure
that recommendations and actions are
properly implemented yes I think that's
I think there's value to that again you
wouldn't want to take away from the
individual responsibility of the area
that it concerned let me give you an
example
um we now once again have a body whose
sole responsibility is preparing Britain
to be resilient to health external
Health threats oxa and Dame Jenny Harris
is a excellent chief executive of AXA
you wouldn't want such a body to replace
AXA or make AXA feel less accountable I
want Jenny Harris and whoever's in her
job to wake up every morning worrying
about the next pandemic and what needs
to be put in place you can of course
supplement that with better resilience
training at the center as well but you
can't you mustn't take away from the the
real burning accountability of the
person in that job and also I one of the
recommendations was that they would
these people would make recommendations
in terms of allocation of budget because
it isn't there's obviously been a
discussion of the impact of budgets in
the last couple of weeks it isn't just
about the total Quantum of budget it's
about how it's spent in this country
this year we spent 53 billion pounds on
physical military defense
access core budget is 450 million pounds
that's less than one percent and yet
over 220 000 people died of covid have
died of covert so far the impact on the
health of the nation and the well-being
of the nation of Health protection is
an order of magnitude bigger than as
currently represented in the oxa budget
and the idea that we spend over 50
billion pounds on defense and under 500
million on AXA is for me completely
indefensible all right
I was asking you in fact about a general
resilience Academy to deal with civil
contingencies you you responded by
reference to
to the United Kingdom
um Health Security Agency yeah that is
of course involved with health emergency
exactly as were you so it's worth having
to cross the board as well yes I
intended to ask you and I perhaps didn't
make that sufficiently plain whether
there was a case for resilience Academy
to deal with civil contingencies for
example a collapse in
critical National infrastructure or a
Cyber attack or or some other Mass event
or catastrophe that which could befall
our nation it's
now Beyond time is it not it is beyond
time my sorry I the reason I got into
budgets is that it's only a central body
that can also make recommendations in
terms of allocation between different
departments as a departmental head you
can't do that yes
is there therefore also a case for
fundamental rethink on this whole CCA
2004 structure and the lead government
Department model
I don't want to intrude into module two
issues sure but but obviously when
dealing with a national crisis yes
it's beyond the ability of a single
Department to be able to cope because of
course all national crises by definition
will have an impact a range of impacts
across government yes I I think that you
need you I I actually support the lead
government department at structure
because you need somebody who feels
accountable for looking out for that
threat all of the time but you then need
a system in the center that is stronger
at holding that accountability holding
feet to the fire and the but the
coordination element of it in when you
get to a massive crisis goes up to the
chain to the Prime Minister anyway and
so that is a role of the Civil
contingencies Secretariat which when you
have a huge crisis like covid then was
replaced with the covert specific
Central sector but some of these issues
Mr Hancock didn't go to you even though
you're the Secretary of State and your
own lead government Department yes but
imagine so so with respect
is that not now in a need for uh for a
much stronger coordinating body not
perhaps just part of the cabinet office
but a stronger body which can ensure
that in the run-up to a crisis in terms
of the preparation the preparedness the
planning
things that need to be elevated to the
highest levels are yes and the way that
I put it is that the goal of it should
be to hold the lead
Department's feet to the fire for
instance if you had one of these bodies
in the center if they tried to do the
job of the of the health secretary as
the category one responder then no then
who regards the guardian far better
would be that they are in a position to
haul in the health secretary and say are
you doing your do doing that enough
because I wasn't called to the National
Security Council for instance in order
to answer those questions in my 18
months as health secretary before the
pandemic struck
finally I want to ask you some questions
please about some other aspects of
the system which you found to be
deficient when you were faced with a
terrible crisis in January of 2020. yeah
you've touched on many of them already
but I just want to summarize the
position in order to be able to to focus
Minds for when we get to the next module
and thereafter yes the areas that
require particular and detailed
consideration yeah
there was obviously this issue therefore
of there being a stockpile of PPE but as
it happened given the sheer number of
casualties
and those who are sick and ill and of
course those who died
the stockpile was completed
uh depleted sorry yes and it was
necessary for the government to try to
secure further supplies through just in
case contracts and
deal with the Mayhem of the
international markets yes
is there therefore an issue which
requires further consideration in
relation to how we make sure that next
time
such stocks as there are such stockpiles
as there are for the particular pandemic
which may eventuate are sufficient or at
least that there is an ability to
improve the numbers to to to increase
the numbers yes in a way that doesn't
leave the sexual status as you are
having to
to make up the deficit so we started
buying
um PPE in January 2020
um
long before it was certain this would
become a global pandemic
um but the problems with the stockpile
were very significant and I'm sure that
we'll come to this in future modules
um what is vital for Preparation is that
there are stockpiles that are accessible
uh pickable in the technical language
um that can be distributed quickly and
can be distributed to all Health and
Social care settings and as I say I
think there should be a legal
requirement on Health and Social care
settings to hold a significant amount of
PPE to be able to get through the early
weeks of a future pandemic because the
sheer logistical complexity of setting
up these Supply chains in in short order
is exceptionally difficult as we as we
learn all right I don't want to ask you
to to address
the solutions or in fact to identify the
specific problems that arose only to
acknowledge that there were very real
difficulties in these areas
the availability of mass diagnostic
testing yes you've already referred to
terrible the availability of Mass
contact tracing systems yes there was no
such thing
obviously there are the NHS related
issues concerning
resilience
bed capacity workforce planning all of
which are issues which you've
um referred to yes there's a bigger
thing there as well within the NHS which
is that you know whilst the discussion
on how much resources the NHS should get
is a highly political one and we've seen
it play out over the last couple of
weeks in this inquiry there is actually
a really big question that the nation
needs to ask itself which is that you
wouldn't have Ascend the whole of your
army out into battle at once you have
spare capacity in case there's a crisis
you have what they call redundancy in
the in the military sense yet every
single day we send our whole Army of the
NHS out into the field and there is no
redundancy we run the NHS incredibly
tight it's an incredibly efficient
organization in the grand scheme of
things despite obvious areas that can be
improved it is overall
run very tight and that means that there
simply isn't the resilience when a
crisis comes but that would require a
materially huge increase in the already
very very large NHS budget but other
countries choose to spend a higher
proportion of GDP on health care and
have that redundancy and it it means
that they are better able to respond
but it also comes back to Doctrine
because no health system or any size
would be able to respond unless you
suppress a virus when it's as bad as
covid-19 but as Milady has already
observed in another context there are
choices that will have to be made and
there is therefore an issue about
resilience and about bed capacity and
surge capacity and so on absolutely for
the future absolutely
and then
in your statement you address issues
such as the changes over time in the
public health structures yes there is an
issue about the the necessary degree of
coordination across the United Kingdom
given the fact that
Health security is a devolved issue yes
but at the same time of course
viruses uh honor No Boundaries
and then finally you say that well they
they honor Geographic boundaries they
honor no administrative boundaries the
fact that we are an island is an
advantage that we uh should use much
more aggressively in future in
preventing a pandemic coming here and
you refer finally to the need to examine
more closely the degree of required
International coordination yes I do I
don't want you to to develop that that
point
The Remains the final issue
um which I think I I'd be grateful for
your views on which
is the degree to which you materially
assisted in the development of
what turned out to be life-saving
vaccine production yes
we heard evidence from uh Jeremy Hunt MP
as to how he assisted to the process by
which the process of the
the UK vaccine Network when he was
Secretary of State and were you also
materially concerned in ensuring that we
had the proper structures in place for
future development of vaccines when you
were Secretary of State yes I thought
this was very important and in fact in
terms of pandemic preparedness given the
reassurances that we were well prepared
this was the area I put most
effort into and I'm and it
um a lot of the preparedness work was
very helpful here and the Oxford vaccine
was essentially built on a project that
started with an attempt to get a vaccine
for uh Ebola that was before my time I
worked to try to enhance the domestic
manufacturing capability and I did a
huge amount of work also on stopping
anti-vax content I was worried about
that for normal everyday vaccines like
MMR and the flu jab but it was also very
important ahead of a pandemic because
the point is that once you have the
right doctrine of suppressing a virus
until the vaccine can make us safe
you've got to make sure that you get the
vaccines and that people have the
confidence to take them so there was a
there was a huge amount of preparation
work in that area that I was directly
involved in
um and that ended up being one of the
areas where we where we performed
incredibly well and we of course had the
first vaccine in the world and Miss tank
my final question
do you know why
no
pathogenic outbreak related exercise
or any governmental policy or guidance
or paper
paid any regard
to the impact or Consequences of
a pandemic
on the vulnerable on members of
our community in in our minority ethnic
sectors
or on the marginalized or otherwise
suffering from inequalities there
appears to have been absolutely no
thought given at all at any time other
than in relation to the obvious point
that there would be a clinical risk
to what the likely impact
would be of a pandemic
say totally
and therefore no thought was given to
how the plans might be adjusted to cater
for that significant risk
it saddens me enormously that
the central work
the the
CMO was planning to do when I appointed
him in October 2019 was to focus on the
reduction of the completely unacceptable
Health inequalities that exist in this
country
the life expectancy of a man born in
Blackpool is 15 years less than a man
born in buckinghamshire and I appointed
Chris witty to the CMO job
based on his proposal that he wanted to
do everything that we could to address
this so Health inequalities were right
at the Forefront of his and my agenda
um the of course the different impact
clinically of a virus on different
groups is absolutely front of mind and
implicit in all of the planning well
that's obvious yeah it has to be
um but in terms of the social and
socio-economic impacts
all I would say is that an assumption
that you're not going to stop a pandemic
running through the population
[Music]
it is but implicitly an assumption and a
decision that those most vulnerable to
it will be hardest hit so the single
best thing we can do to protect those
who are most vulnerable is stop
viruses from killing hundreds of
thousands of people and it brings me and
we end on my on the central my central
contention which is you've got to work
out there are costs of lockdown you've
got to work out whether the impact of
the virus is going to be worse than the
cost of lockdown and if it is going to
be worse as was the case with covid-19
you've got to hit it hard and very very
early
but Mr Hancock as you now have
acknowledged
our system of preparedness for being
able to deal with the pandemic was
materially hindered and weakened and the
sad reality is that as part of that
failure
there was no consideration of the needs
of the most vulnerable at all
there was consideration on a clinical
basis of the needs of the most
vulnerable but not on a socioeconomic
basis and if I may and finally
um
this was of course an unprecedented
pandemic in anybody's lifetime
and
those who worked so hard to respond to
it
had to respond from the basis of the
preparation that there was
um and they did work incredibly hard and
I think everybody in in the health area
that I was responsible for
gave their all
with humility in the face of this virus
and unprecedented event
um but
that just underlines why it's so
important that we get the right lessons
out of this inquiry
the Lions led by structural donkeys Mr
Hancock personally everyone gave their
all but the system
was not fit for purpose was it that's
absolutely right and it goes it is that
is a that is a pro was a problem Across
the Western world and it goes back a
long long way in the assumptions
underpinning how we plan for these
things and it must never happen again
Milady that concludes my questioning Mr
Hancock
there is one area
submitted by covid-19 brief families for
justice UK and Northern covid-19 breed
families for justice for which you've
given permission
Mr Weatherby sorry not quite finished Mr
Hancock no problem
yes you very much
Mr Hancock
um I ask you a few questions on behalf
of the covid brief families for justice
which represents the interests of many
many bereaved families from across the
United Kingdom and it's centered around
the pandemic flu bill which was one of
the two key work streams that were kept
going
um when most of the rest of the
refreshers we've heard it called
um was because of brexit
is that right so that gives the
importance with which you
um looked at the pandemic flu Bill yes
and and I would say it was one of the
most important things to come out of
operation sickness okay I want to just
explore the background of that and what
was in it very very briefly indeed
um but you have
um already indicated to Mr Keith
the the 2011 Doctrine strategy
um was woefully inadequate yes and you
put that in your statement yes and I
just want to just read that one
paragraph from your statement to flesh
that out yes
um clearly this is your words clearly
the approach in the 2011 strategy was
woefully inadequate I have no idea why
the 2011 strategy did not consider the
approach taken by countries affected by
SARS and learn the lessons for the UK I
also do not know why the who considered
the UK one of the best prepared
countries in the world when our
strategic approach did not consider it
possible to take social distancing
measures necessary to stop the spread of
a killer disease yes yes and so you're
emphasizing the lack of learning and the
emphasis around social distancing
measures yes and that would of course
include lockdowns absolutely yeah okay
and you've also elsewhere paragraph 29
refer to the who as an authoritative
Source yes so you're giving respect to
the view of the who yes well it is the
yeah UN agency in this area it needs
radical reform but nevertheless it is
we'll leave that one for a different day
but you're regarding that as an
authoritative source in 2018 at
precisely the time that this work on the
pandemic flew bill was being
um completed or being looked at
considered
um The Who as part of its Global
influenza program published an update to
a document which had been around since
2005. entitled a checklist for pandemic
influenza risk and impact management I
just want to take you to one passage of
that okay and it's uh one eight double
seven four eight please
and Page One have you got it in front of
you there
I've got the title screen and not the
paragraph no no
um just want to orientate us all this is
the this is the who document 2018.
um I'm going to take you to page 11 in a
minute
um in the interest of time I'm just
going to flag up one other reference
which is at Page Six
where this document refers to the
importance of prevention and mitigation
and not simply response and Recovery
right so by 2018 the who are putting out
guidance which
um underlines the necessity prevention
and mitigation and not just response and
Recovery which I think is one of your
points isn't it it's one of the problems
with the UK's Doctrine well I I I
haven't seen this document
um it depends what you mean by
prevention and mitigation because the
initial
containment and an attempt to contain
the virus was part of the UK's plans the
problem with the UK plan was that once
we got to community transmission it was
wrongly assumed it wasn't stop possible
to stop the spread yeah a mitigation in
this context
tends to mean dealing with the
consequences which I which which is not
which is not good enough well that with
respect to his response rather than
mitigation well I I'd be very happy to
read the document and consider it well
okay can I take you to page 11 please
and we will just have a quick look at
this because this is the important
passage of it and with respect to the
pandemic flu Bell and
um
hasn't come up in front of me yes it has
so this is uh paragraph 2.2 within this
document and it's added legal and policy
issues which is why it's relevant to
what I'm asking you about with the bill
yeah so the rationale the public health
measures during a pandemic are designed
to reduce the spread of the pandemic
virus and save lives in some
circumstances it may be necessary to
overall existing laws or individual
human rights in order to implement
measures that are in the best interests
of Community Health
then I'll skip the next sentence again
in the interests of time and the end of
that paragraph these decisions need a
legal framework to ensure transparent
assessment and Authority for the
measures being considered as well as
coherence with relevant International
laws yes so here's the who
saying that you need to consider the
measures and then you need to have the
um the legal backing in place before the
problem strikes yes
next part this document splits the
guidance into essential
what the who
regards as essential and what is
um
desirable yeah
this is under essential
and then the first bullet point review
existing legislation policies or other
government instruments relevant to
pandemic influenza risk management
and
Etc
yes yes and that's what you're doing yes
around 2018 with the pandemic flu Bell
yes and then the second bullet point
yeah all that and this is the important
that was all in the yeah yeah assess the
legal basis for all public health
measures
that are likely to be proposed during
pandemic response such as
isolation or quarantine of infected
individuals people suspected of being
infected or people from areas where
pandemic influenza infection is
established so a legal measure in place
for an emergency to restrict the
ordinary rights of people who are
infected or may be infected yes yes
second bullet point travel or movement
restriction yeah I.E on leaving or
entering areas where pandemic influenza
infection is established
so travel and movement yep would include
lockdown yeah
closure of educational institutions and
prohibition of mass Gatherings yeah yeah
okay
so
um
all
relatively straightforward in concept
just one point I would
um challenge which is you said travel
restrict or movement restrictions that
means lockdown that's not right no no
what it doesn't have in there is a
stay-at-home order
because the isolational quarantine of
infected individuals is is for as it
says infected individuals okay I said
would include lockdowns in parentheses
that is on leaving or entering areas
where no that's no a lockdown is where
people are required by law to stay at
home which is different I'm not going to
um fence with you over that one it'll be
really matters because
if the question is given that the who
published this in 2018 why didn't we
have it in place right if that if that's
the question
the pandemic
flu draft bill which became the
coronavirus Act
um and the public health act 1984 has
the the uh legal framework for all of
this in it
um however
the review compliance with obligations
under ihr
um a sentence in the top bullet point
that ihr includes the rule that you
should not close your borders in a
pandemic and the fact that the second
bullet point does not include a
stay-at-home order
precisely supports my point that there
was not
consideration given even at the who
level to the requirement for lockdown
okay well the travel restriction is not
lockdown okay I I haven't got the time
to to go into the international Health
regulations with you we can perhaps deal
with that in a different way sure but
here you have a list of straightforward
sensible options which the who
um reference to the spread of the
pandemic or stopping the spread of the
pandemic yes
um and there are options which are
likely
um to be proposed in an emergency
situation such as a pandemic yes
that's what it said that wasn't the
policy of the UK it wasn't the policy of
the okay no time indeed
um because we get to the pandemic flu
bill
um and in in light of what you you've
just said I think we will need to put it
up just the contents page uh and it's
two three one one eight please
so this is the the bill as drafted yeah
um dated uh 2020 in fact so this is
after the work presumably is completed
and what we see here is is the bill with
has Clauses which relate to the
emergency registration of health
professionals yes A rafter Provisions
dealing with
um easy the easing of ordinary business
as usual duties within the mental health
system and the health system and an
Indemnity in terms of health care yeah
now which of that list that we've just
looked at from The Who guidance which of
that list is in this
um pandemic flu Bill Mr Hancock uh
um I don't know but I do know that of
that list in the who guidance many of
those are in the public health act 1984
because it was the public health act
1984 that we used as the legal basis for
uh for restrictions yeah so um in fact
it's Clause 14 is the temporary closure
of educational institutions so the only
one of that list that made its way into
this bill
um is the uh restriction or temporary
closure of educational facilities right
so um you've you've referred to other
acts but this is the work stream which
is refreshing the or supposed to be
refreshing or updating the
um uh Doctrine
and this is the bill which is supposed
to be there to give you an Armory and an
emergency situation and it doesn't
follow
um this authoritative Source from the
who how did how was that allowed to
happen because the other recommendations
from the who were already in law in this
country in the public health act 1984.
um if I may say so
um I essentially think that this the
core Point you're making which is that
we should have been ready and had legal
um
um powers in place and we should be
ready to lock down
um that I agree with wholeheartedly and
I agree with it and I think that
you know on uh to do justice
as much nothing can bring the people who
died back and each and every one
but we must learn that lesson that we
need to take the measures necessary
early to stop
a future pandemic from killing people
yes
um but but to say they're not in this
bill and it
um without considering what other bills
they might already be doesn't really
prove that point okay well I'm sure we
can look at at the legislation as we go
along but this this is the work stream I
know but we did but I I use that
legislation extensively I understand
that the public health act 1984 very
well and what I can tell you is that the
who recommendations in 2018 other than
on temporary closure of educational
institutions those powers are available
as far as I understand it in the public
health finally just in terms of the
devolved Nations it's right isn't it
that this legislation
um was
um developed as draft legislation was
developed with some input from the
development yes it's also right that
none of them used it in in the event
because they have their own other
legislation already on the statute book
I mean I I actually think that we could
do part of the reason for a need to
reform the 1984 Act is to have a uk-wide
approach because I think that
um whilst it's totally appropriate to
devolve
um health and the NHS because of the
nature of how pandemics spread it would
be far better to respond to the next
pandemic on a uk-wide basis rather than
in England Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland bases and I think that way we
would save more lives yes are you
finally this are you able to point to to
any documents or any briefing or any
meeting where the fact of um powers or
legislation being elsewhere was a factor
in what was included in in their strap
Bill oh yes of course that was the
important consideration in what to put
into the build because one of the things
that parliamentary Council who draft uh
bills absolutely hate is legislating in
an area where a policy is already
legislated for yes okay so that is a
material consideration yes
that's all I asked thank you thank you
Milady we've received an email from
bereave Francis Justice Camry
who wish I think perhaps vicariously to
ask for permission for a point to be put
to Mr Hancock who said in the course of
his evidence that
coronavirus was the first
Coronavirus
known to be or the first coronavirus
that could be transmitted
asymptomatically
um
the position is as the chart that you
directed be prepared amply demonstrates
is that MERS and SARS were also are also
asymptomatically transmitted and
therefore
there is clear evidence to to correct
that position
I don't want to give evidence about it
but there is that material there in the
chart but perhaps I could be permitted
to to ask you one question Mr Hancock in
light of the question from bereave
Founders Justice Camry the transmission
rates
in relation to ma the MERS and SARS one
yes are of course very different yes yes
um what I stated was the uh clinical
fact as I was advised uh at the uh
during the debate about asymptomatic
transmission which no doubt we'll cover
in M2 because it was absolutely Central
uh to the challenges of the early
response to the to the pandemic thank
you melody that's that concludes Mr
hackleton thank you very much Mr Hancock
that completes um the evidence should be
given certainly in this module
um thank you for your help okay thank
you
two o'clock all right
the next witness is Mr Duncan Selby who
is appearing this afternoon at the
inquiry through a link from the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia and I hope my lady that
you can see Mr Selby on your screen I
can thank you Mr Selby would you please
take the affirmation
Sam good afternoon everyone
I do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm that the evidence I
shall give shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
thank you Mr Selby thank you for the
assistance that you've given to the
inquiry so far you have provided a
witness statement which we can see at
19268 now that's appearing on my screen
is it also appearing on your screen
um yes it is now it's rather small but
yes all right it's being enlarged is
that helping at all yes that's that's
better excellent all right well um
whenever I show a document to you I'll
make sure that the document presenter
makes it as large as possible for you
firm Please Mr Selby that that is your
whip
to go to it but it is signed um at page
14. and is that statement Mr Selby true
to the best of your knowledge and belief
yes it is thank you very much we can
take that down
I will ask you questions and I hope that
all of them are are clear and that you
understand them if you don't then please
just let me know and I will ask it again
or try and rephrase it and if you need a
break at any time Mr Selby please just
let us know and we will break for your
convenience and please keep your voice
as loud as you can so that the
stenographer can hear you for the
transcript
can you also confirm Please Mr Selby
that you have read the witness
statements provided to the inquiry by
Professor Dane Jenny Harris and
and also Professor Isabel Oliver
yes and uh sorry there was Interruption
for about three seconds I hope this
isn't going to happen so do I could you
could you repeat the question please yes
of course I was asking Mr Selby if you
can confirm that you've read the witness
statements of Professor Dame Jenny
Harris and Professor Isabel Oliver on
behalf of the ukhsa
yes I have thank you very much
and do you broadly agree with what has
been set out in those witness statements
so far as public health England is
concerned
yes thank you I want to begin by setting
out your professional background and
qualifications so far as they're
relevant to this inquiry you have
qualifications in health and Hospital
management and Health and Social Care
Management you held various NHS posts in
Scotland and London between 1980 and
1986 then in
1997 you became chief executive of South
West London and St George's mental
health NHS Trust
January 22 you became chief executive of
the South East London strategic health
authority and in November 2003 you
worked for the Department of Health
initially as the Director general of
programs and performance for the NHS
then as director general of NHS
commissioning and in July of 2007 you
became chief executive of Brighton and
Sussex University Hospitals and then
chief executive of Public Health England
from July of 2012 to August of 2020.
thank you
in her witness statement to the inquiry
Professor Dame Sally Davis has expressed
a view that UK Public Health institutes
that deal with infectious disease
outbreaks should be professionally led
by a clinical scientist
it's right Mr Selby that you don't hold
any medical or scientific qualifications
do you
no I don't and that is unusual
um for a National Public Health
Institute if I may I should have said
that I'm also the president of I am free
which is the international Gathering of
national public health institutes it's
the world's Gathering of the of the uh
Dame Jennys if you like
um in 115 uh 150 institutes around the
world and I think I might have been
unique
um in not being clinically or public
health uh qualified
um
do you feel in any way that that
hampered you in in carrying out your
role as chief executive of Public Health
England
well I thought deeply about this and and
you know with all the genuine humility
no I don't think it did because being a
chief executive is not the same thing as
being a clinical scientist or an
academic I think it could prove to be a
great Advantage uh potentially to have
that background but that's not what a
chief executive is there to do and
um I'm fairly experienced as a chief
executive I've made lots of good
decisions and lots of less good
decisions but I'm definitely very
experienced and that was the basis on on
which I was appointed and and I never
pretended to be otherwise
um and the you know my interview
included the chief medical officer at
the time and and as you know it involved
bringing together quite a complex set of
um bodies into a and to create something
new something that hadn't happened
before in this country so
uh I'll assist there all right thank you
very much for that answer and indeed
we've been through the extensive
experience that you had of acting as a
chief executive before taking up that
post at Public Health England but but I
I suspect that you may have been asked a
similar question uh when you gave an
interview in 2013 to the Lancet because
I asked about your experience in public
health your answer appears to have been
you can fit my public health credentials
on a postage stamp is that right
I did say that it was a bit unkind of
them it was meant to be a light-hearted
introduction and and I have had lots of
involvement with health inequalities and
public health because in my years as the
direct agenda of performance I was
instrumental in six priorities for the
NHS one of them being Health
inequalities it was about the NHS
cardiovascular cancer and so on and then
in my strategic health authority days I
had a director of Public Health for the
student health authority
um I'm a mental health that was
essentially a public health agenda which
we might talk about but Professor Marmot
I think would recognize that if you get
it right for mental health you get it
right for the Public's health so it was
a little unkind but if you read the
whole of that interview it was balanced
out and I think the communications
director at the time said I wish you had
said
um but it was it was meant to be like
that thank you and respectful it was
meant to be respectful about what I
didn't know yes well thank you very much
for that answer Mr Selby and I I know
because I I've spoken to you before
um you took your affirmation and began
to give evidence that you were able to
follow the evidence yesterday from
Professor Dane Jenny Harris and so I'm
able to take some of my questioning in
in short fashion with you today
you will have seen that we covered
evidence with Dame Jenny yesterday about
the rather complex restructuring of
Public Health in England brought about
by the Health and Social Care Act of
2012. and the the key differences
between the HPA and phe and so we
established the following that the HPA
was an executive non-departmental body
and was replaced by phe which was an
executive agency of the then Department
of Health
that phe brought together under the
management of a single organization the
previous distinct strands of Public
Health namely public protection Public
Health Improvement and Health Care
Public Health
that phe worked with local authorities
who were given new responsibility for
improving the health of local
populations that role having been
transferred from the pcts and that
public health England also worked with
the directors of Public Health who for
England were employed by local
authorities as strategic leaders for
public health and health inequalities in
local communities
we also looked at the various structural
changes over time to the phe local and
Regional teams
so I'm going to ask you Mr Selby if you
have any Reflections on the impact of
all those structural changes in
particular or on the following issues
firstly the clarity and understanding of
eprr roles and responsibilities
was there in your view any confusion as
a result of the what I'm going to
describe as rather complicated
overlapping and or blurred statutory
responsibilities
so I think initially
um there was a lot of planning to be
done because this was new for local
government and then Jenny spoke
yesterday about that being quite a
difficult transition and I agree with
that but it was about moving if you like
from a place where directors of Public
Health had been for many many years to a
place where they could make a bigger
difference and could have a bigger
impact so I think it was very worthwhile
very brave and courageous with the
public health directors to make that
shift but it did bring with it a whole
lot of new relationships within councils
with colleagues as well as with the
health the health sector and over time
um that that became some concern and the
house the house select committee asked
us to look at this
and to be more assured about these
arrangements and I think you've you've
you you know I've seen the I've been
reminded of the Assurance exercise that
we went Council in 2016 which was quite
positive but it did involve still a lot
of further training and the sport
interventions and different parts of the
country so I don't I don't think I think
inevitably
um because it was a big change but it
was a very worthwhile change I in my
heart I will always say I would believe
that that was the right thing to do but
it did it did take time
um and it did involve a lot of new
learning for a lot of people
in terms of funding although
all their budget for local authorities
we heard that the public health Grant
was reduced in real terms by 14 between
2015 and 2021 were you aware of that at
the time
yes it was very disappointing and you
know I spoke with the then Secretary of
State Jeremy Hunt and then obviously
with the ministers that
were responsible for public health it
was it was actually a it was a very
disappointing time
um in 2015 uh Mr Hunt managed to
negotiate a lot more money for the NHS
but the treasury made a condition of
that that Department of Health reduced
its budget and and there was really only
two places that the Department of Health
could look for that one was health
education England and of course we
needed more doctors and nurses and we
had to train more so it was public
health England and I had a conversation
with Mr Han where he asked me for 50 of
the budget in order to fund the the NHS
um and obviously that wasn't going to
happen because uh local government were
then responsible for essential services
like School nursing and addiction
services and no smoking clinics and all
sorts of things that were terribly
important and of course but there was a
negotiation and the treasury won that
argument and it was an initial 200
million reduction I'm afraid that then
led to every year after that further
reductions
um I might add one thing that James Dame
Journey didn't
um or wasn't didn't come out
sufficiently when this money was
originally earmarked for Royal
government it was essentially only what
pcts had been spending
and there was great variation across the
country and even though we had three
attempts to try and get a good fix on
what was being spent in the NHS when we
eventually settled it there was a
seven-fold difference we built
inequality in from the outset and the
plan was that over time through growth
we would even that out
and that was what was so terribly
disappointing about what happened in
2015 because the ability to even that
out was then taken taken away so what
were the what was the Practical effect
of that consistent reduction in budget
how did that manifest itself within
Public Health
well again team Journey yesterday and I
definitely agree with this this local
government uh the most fiscally able of
all the public health services they have
managed to manage on less
more than anyone else and they are very
good at that but you're talking very
small amounts of money that have huge
impacts locally so a million pound
reduction in a year on a budget could
mean that they couldn't support children
at Children's Center I might not be able
to continue to to offer home support for
for for people with long-term conditions
a whole series of effects so you know
the the the but the actual Grant of
three billion or so is a fraction of the
spend in the NHS so any
um reduction on that was going to have a
a bigger uh you know have a bigger
impact it was just depressing
um that this and because at that time it
was so energizing that we had this
opportunity at a local level to bring
together uh local knowledge local
leadership with specialist support from
public health England lots of expertise
to try and do the right thing in a very
sort of local way but you have to fund
you have to fund that if you if you want
to see see that happen yes we've heard
of a practice
called top slicing where local
authorities would reallocate ring fenced
Public Health budgets to other services
do you know for instance Mr Selby
whether or not pandemic planning or or
local risk Assessments in relation to
pandemic planning was was one of the
areas that that was likely to to be
um to suffer from the the lack of
funding in other words we're local
authorities in the business of of taking
money that that might have been used for
those matters and putting it elsewhere
to more acute problems
so there was a loss of consent the local
government and a huge financial pressure
we would want to use the public health
Grant as small as it was it was enabling
of other things
and we instituted an arrangement with
the national office where the use of the
Grant had to be approved by the director
of Public Health and was signed off by
the director of Public Health as having
been appropriately used this was to try
and give some protection to direct this
as a public health against directors of
Finance or chief Executives who wanted
to take the money but I can't tell you
is uh whether that affected eprr
um in in its in a significant way I'd
like to think not because these were
very small resources anyway and they
were all involved in local Health
resilience Partnerships where that sort
of Gap I think would become apparent all
right thank you well I'm going to return
later on in my questioning to the system
of subsidiarity and local and
preparedness but but just touching upon
directors of Public Health was there a
shortage of directors of Public Health
due to retirements and recruitment
problems
uh it it did fluctuate in the early days
again in Jenny it made the point but
quite a number of the more experienced
closer to retirement directors of Public
Health took the opportunity to retire at
the point of the change and then there
was a core part of folk that did move
over that just didn't find that it
worked for them it was it was such a
different environment to the NHS they've
been used to and they either went back
to the NHS and some in some role or went
on to do something else and so over time
you saw uh well we paid a lot of
attention as public health England to
this in training uh bringing on
professionally developing younger uh
potential future directors of Public
Health and I think it's all in Dame
Jenny's statement about different
programs we put together we had about
well we had exactly 152 local
authorities we had about 130 directors
because small authorities used to share
their director and that was that was
perfectly normal so I'm not up to date
with the exact numbers but I do I do
think it was reasonably healthy
um reasonably healthy
um towards the sort of
2017-18-19 years
do you agree with the view that the
links between NHS staff and Public
Health Specialists became fractured
which also affected Community infection
prevention and control
yeah I think it became more difficult
and one of my greatest regrets was that
in strengthening the relationship
between public health and public health
England but previously HPA and and the
local government came at some expense of
having removed that capability and that
experience from the NHS not just at PCT
therefore but at strategic Health
thought or whatever the management
Arrangements were at that time and I was
very concerned about that and in 20 in
2018 2019 reintroduced directors of
Public Health into the what was then the
seven leadership teams of the NHS and
had been an interagnum of what would
that be at least five years so I I
definitely think that we lost our way
um about the NHS and they were very very
uh glad to have this back now what did
this mean for infection
protection and control it I don't have
enough visibility on that I would I
accept that it was uh it it that the
focus was diminished the the sort of
Public Health focus on This was
um if you like less it was more about
what hospitals were doing because
they've always had a big focus on this
um I know this to be true
um but I think community service is very
much relied on their
um that when they had their Public
Health responsibilities for for this I
but I I genuinely I I you'd have to ask
NHS England I think
um because they they were actually
responsible for this
the inquiries had that some parts of the
English Public Health Community have
raised concerns about the extent to
which Public Health England as an
executive agency of the Department of
Health was able to act as an independent
advocate for public health and to set
its own strategic priorities do you want
to say anything about the lack of or
perceived lack of independence of Public
Health England from the government
well
um I never felt constrained I mean there
was never a moment when in fact
occasion in the eight years
produced or published we did negotiate
about timing and there were issues about
you know other things going on at the
time but there was never a moment not
one moment where we were asked to please
don't say that or can you take that out
or can you redact that
that and in a sense I mean when you look
at the media about public health England
over the years I don't think you'd have
any doubt about our willingness to speak
out
um and you know the libertarian end of
politics in in Britain which we didn't
exist
um and you know they were always
complaining about what we were uh what
what we were advocating for so I I don't
I don't think I don't think that and
then Jenny spoke yesterday about the
particular the particular protection
that we had for our scientists and our
public health professionals of all
different forms although part of the
Civil Service they we had a special
Court approved by the treasury because
the Civil Service Corps doesn't allow
civil servants to speak to the media
without ministerial Authority and that
did not apply to Public Health England
and I was very proud of that that was
one of the early successes to explain
that actually our voice may not have
been loud in enough at times or we might
not have got it right and others might
have said that you know we should have
been doing other things or concentrating
the other things but there was never any
doubt in my mind that we were uh we you
know and I would have resigned
unquestionably
um it was a it was absolutely the
heartbeat if we were independent to
science and evidence we were not
independent of government
and that that is that is often
misunderstood
there's there's not a national public
health agency on the planet that is
independent of its government because
you can't separate politics from public
health but Independence to science and
evidence definitely
right
with such a broad Public Health remit
how did Public Health England under your
stewardship as chief executive decide
which public health strategies to
prioritize each year
so the heart of it was the global burden
of disease
um which was the if you like the health
profile of the country uh what was
killing people what was taking people
away early in a in an avoidable way and
then Michael marmot's work was hugely
instrumental about well that might be
what people are experiencing but it
doesn't tell you much about why or what
you can do about it so we try to balance
across Health Improvement and health
protection you've heard from many that
these are inseparable things
um you can't have a protected population
unless you have a healthy one
um and and so we set priorities balanced
across uh The Wider determinants with
the biggest priorities so for example uh
we would tackle of course we would
tackle tobacco use and we would tackle
obesity but we also had HIV
and TB the start to life that was
Michael marmot's biggest advice to me
um that we should focus on the beginning
the beginning of life so it was a
combination of those two sources of uh
the best public health evidence that's
available that that helped us to to make
these judgments and we made those
judgments with the the Department of
Health you know we didn't we didn't just
say and and published so we negotiated
we spoke to NHS England we spoke to
Partners
the thought sector and and of course
with ministers and with the chief
medical officers so the the priorities
were if you like agreed priorities but
those were the two sources for for how
we came about them
as you know Matt Hancock gave evidence
to the inquiry this morning
um and although he wasn't asked about
this in evidence at paragraph 99 of his
statement he talks about the the
conglomeration of different public
health issues within uh Public Health
England and in his view it was a mistake
to create Public Health England as a
body responsible for tackling
non-communicable Public Health like
obesity as well as communicable diseases
and preparing for pandemics because his
view is that it was inevitable in those
circumstances that the organization
Public Health England was spend more
attention on tackling issues in front of
it rather than worrying about the next
pandemic do you agree that more
attention of Public Health England was
spent on tackling tackling
non-communicable public health issues
rather than pandemic preparedness
so I've thought a lot about this of
course
um I don't think no I don't believe in
that our first priority beginning and
end was Health protection that was our
resin Detra it was what we did 24 hours
seven days a week and you've got the
data about the thousands and thousands
of uh outbreaks of men and and the the
sort of big events that happened over
those years and James only spoke about
them but I would have added others to
them as well
um that were managed by public health
England Health protection with Partners
but very much without expertise at no
point not ever did we compromise on on
that I don't say that with hindsight I
say that up with the
um what would how could I describe it
that was our core purpose but you cannot
keep people safe unless you address the
right determinants and you had witness
statements I thought the one from
Richard Horton was between particularly
good about how you can't tackle Health
protection without tackling Health
Improvement and inequalities and so
there are many different ways in which
you can organize
um to best effect and different
countries approach this in different
ways some some have separation uh most
are moving towards integration but it's
not really that for me the question is
how do you deploy against the
um the Essential Health functions set
out by Geneva which include all these
different areas in your context in the
way where you can get the best is like
the best from from that investment
there's not an answer that says and it
is this but I do not agree with the uh
prior secretary of state that
um you can that you can separate these
you have to find a way of bringing them
together that may be organization they
or there might be other ways in which
that might be done but you can't frankly
have anywhere and going on too much Mr
Selby sorry to interrupt could you also
try and speak a bit slower don't worry
you're not the first witness to speak
too quickly we've all done it um so if
you could just try I know it's difficult
but
thank you I'm so sorry normally I speak
very slowly so it's just my forgive me I
may be getting a little bit animated Mr
Selby so it's probably yes
I want to move on please to ask you
about uh Public Health England's
responsibilities for preparing for and
responding to pandemics and remind you
of what you say at paragraph 46 of your
witness statement you say in my view
Public Health England carried its
emergency Health Protection work up to
the point of January 2020 in the way
that it was asked to do by ministers it
is also my view that although Public
Health England was not mandated or
funded for at scale pandemic Readiness
and response it did deliver on the tasks
and responsibilities which were mandated
by the Department of Health and Social
care and the chief medical officer
throughout the first phases of the
covid-19 pandemic
what did you mean when you said that in
your view Public Health England was not
mandated for at scale pandemic Readiness
and response
so the the big gap was mass testing
and Mass contact tracing because the the
flu plan didn't didn't ever envisit it
that would be necessary and all the
thinking that I know you've explored
extensively about Mayors and the
technical
High consequence infectious disease if
none of that was uh was required a a
mass response that required what we
called in public health England a large
scale
uh response but the numbers were in the
few hundreds not what what was
eventually requires and there had never
been any discussion at any point with
anyone in my discussions with the
Secretary of State the chief medical
officer
um the Ford and uh current or in any at
place about the scale of pandemic that
we faced so when when I look at the the
budget for public health England it is
it is one quarter of one percent it is
as a 0.23 of one percent of
the NHS budget it doesn't even add up to
the cost of a small hospital and for
this we ran amazing I mean I don't wish
with but you know gold standard
um science at Portland down in colandale
and our regional Laboratories and
everything else that we've been speaking
about this aft this afternoon it was
just not ever part of the uh the remit
you know it was never Pat it was never
part of what we were asked to do my my
um my reflection about the and I know
it's module two is it not we're standing
that I'm intensely proud of what public
health England were able to do in those
first few months
um because everybody everybody had to
pull together
and one of the benefits of Public Health
England was that we had scale and
allowed us to to to be so they draw on
everyone to come together
have I answered your question please do
come back I I may not have I I think you
have to to a certain extent I want to to
ask you some questions about the UK
UK pandemic prepare
parity of 2011. about which I know you
will be familiar because
um whilst Public Health England may not
have had any mandate from the dhsc in
relation to mass testing or contact
tracing and indeed there's there's no
provision in that strategy for those uh
for for those levels of preparedness
um the inquiry has heard from several
witnesses including Mr Hancock this
morning that one of the major flaws in
that strategy was the doctrine that that
lay behind it that it was based on a
premise that it would not be possible to
Halt the pandemic and and that the plan
was really a cleanup plan rather than a
plan to prevent the spread
um do you agree firstly that that that
that that was a major flaw in the plan
in the strategy
I'm not I'm not really qualified to say
um about what the the doctrine might
have been because I would have looked to
Medical scientific
colleagues to be able to to to respond
to that
what I would say is that I I agreed with
Dame Jenny on this that it was entirely
sensible for
um the country to have an influenza
influenza pandemic plan uh even if
that's not what we then faced it would
have been negligent not to have had such
a plan
um and pretty much every country I think
would agree with that
um but I I never thought into well what
happened how did you prevent that how do
you prevent um
um
such a thing happening and I and I I
it's definitely for for
um for discussion
right but the assumption that that lay
behind the strategy was that 50 of the
population May well be infected
if one takes that assumption what was
public health England's responsibility
in terms of the assumption that lay
behind the strategy what what what plans
and and preparations and assessments was
public health England expected to do
so our plan was in the first phases was
the detection and the assessment phases
so of course I do recognize the numbers
so our responsibility was to to know
what was coming through the surveillance
systems that we had and then to uh
develop the the assay the test necessary
um adapt if if necessary and then roll
that out to Laboratories principally in
the NHS
um again
something we might want to explore but
in my statement and I think in Dean
Jenny is about the difference between
Public Health microbiology and
diagnostic micropology which is often
misunderstood
um and so our our role in addition to
eprl of course and supporting the the
whole
um the country with guidance and the
necessary sort of Public Health advice
was essentially in first of all knowing
what was coming towards us and then
being able to get a test out to the NHS
so that they could do the Diagnostics
and was public health England in a
position from 2011 when this strategy
was in place to ensure the capacity for
testing up to 50 of the population if
this if this indeed took place no
because you wouldn't that my my
understanding is you wouldn't be testing
50 of the population you would you would
be testing for surveillance and research
purposes you would be testing just to
know what was happening and and you
would be doing uh ongoing surveillance
to be looking for any changes in the in
the virus
um so if emphatically it wasn't what we
then faced
um
um but but it did that it was that clear
enough yes and so is it your evidence Mr
Selby that in terms of the the
assumptions are set out in the strategy
Public Health England would have been in
a position to provide that level of
testing if the um if this assumption
that was set out in the strategy had
come to fruition
sincerely believe that
do you agree that it was a another flaw
to the plan that it only dealt with
influenza and despite there being a line
within the strategy suggesting that the
plan had to be flexible that in fact
there was
um no advice as to how that flexibility
should be practically employed and that
a better plan would have been a generic
respiratory plan
I do all right
finally were you aware that during the
course of the period of time that passed
between 20 and 11 and the onset of the
covid pandemic that this plan was never
updated were you aware of that at the
time
no it didn't it didn't really get past
my Consciousness I I know you had
yesterday about Nayak Nayak yes which is
our and that was constantly updated and
that was if you like our agnostic
um the response plan uh which by 2016
Incorporated conops which I know you
talked about yesterday and was developed
every year
um sorry uh refreshed every year from
Lessons Learned exercises all sorts of
events that had happened and we had
Assurance processes that I think were
very good and were then sent up for
external Assurance to to the Department
of Health but but the actual flu plan or
that that that never it wasn't conscious
on my conscience
is it right that the all threats plan
Nia had been exercised and updated from
time to time but the pandemic influenza
response plan set out in 2014 had not
been updated since since that was first
published as set out by Dame Jenny
yesterday yes I'd recognize that my my
point is that the night up was the
operational plan that we could apply in
and and did in many sorts of different
um scenarios but the 2014 flu plan
because because it reflected the 2011 DH
plan there was I think a sense that we
would wait until and then there were
various things that happened over those
subsequent years not least brexit that I
think just kept pushing that back if I
could turn the clock back and I wish I
could on so many fronts then you know
obviously we just said well hold on that
just needs to be but it would just still
being a flu plan
um it would have still been a plan that
didn't assume what then happened yes you
will be aware that we established
yesterday with Dame Jenny that the flu
plan was out of date in several respects
not only in relation to uh the
structures within Public Health England
which had changed between 2014 and the
onset of covid but also the wrong
description of the threats committee
which itself was abolished by 2019. are
you concerned Mr Selby that there was in
place during your watch an important
plan that that was not updated in any
respect over the six years between its
Inception and the covert pandemic
hitting
yes of course and I'm accountable for
that
all right thank you
um
I'd like to move on
to look at some minutes from an
oversight meeting which took place in
October of 2017. there are
179643 please
and can we go to the entry at 17 126.
which I think is at page five
this is the phe emergency
response and uh epr oversight group and
at 17126 we can see this that the group
discussed the plans and raised several
comments regarding the coordination with
NHS plans and it was noted that
engagement with NHS England was critical
as they would be responsible for the
patient pathway and these were also an
issue with private laboratory there was
also an issue with private Laboratory
Testing where phe is not notified of
results
and then if we can go please a little
further down to one two seven and one
two eight it was queried how the plan
fitted in with the work undertaken with
the hcid program somebody noted that
further discussions with someone else
and Mike Jacobs of the NHS are needed
urgently to ensure this plan fits with
the hcid work to ensure there is no
contradiction in plans
and the meeting agreed the plan could be
published as an internal draft to staff
with the caveat that the document is
interim and not to be shared outside of
the organization DT to link with GD
regarding wording for the draft release
of the document to ensure staff are
aware of its status now I hope that you
were able to follow that Mr Selby this
is a discussion of a group in relation
to the MERS plan wasn't it
right that's what I want to just to
clarify okay and and I want to just
explore with you the fact that these
notes suggest that as of October 2017
this plan wasn't finalized because there
were some outstanding queries about how
the plan fitted in with work undertaken
by the hcid program
um are you able to help us with what
those concerns were looking at these
notes now
I imagine JH is Jenny Harris
um and of course Mike Jacobs was the
lead
clinician for the hcid
um
um Center at the Royal free and was very
involved we were all very involved with
each other over the Ebola outbreak and
um and so my sense of what you're saying
is that there was a natural we need to
get this together we need to make sure
that it's coordinated that people that
you know that there's alignment I
believe it did actually work out because
we used it um in 2018 for the mass case
and we used it subsequently for other
monkey pox being the one that I can most
remember
um but I can't remember the detail of at
that time what the uh what the concern
might be that I'm satisfied as much as I
can be that they were talking to each
other which is what I would hope for yes
well whilst it's laudable perhaps that
the that there is a a
um an attempt to organize joined up
thinking with the high consequence
infectious disease program yes our
understanding is uh that in fact this
plan was never finalized it remained as
a an interim plan and although you
suggest that it could have been utilized
during the MERS outbreak in 2018 the
information that the inquiry has is that
these discussions that were expected to
be undertaken did not in fact lead to
the plan being finalized does that
Accord with your recollection of what
might have happened
I regret I don't I can't say and I'm I
would what I would be doing is would be
asking uh
UK HSA if they could clarify that
because I'm I'm surprised by that well
that that's what we will do but but I
think you've probably answered my next
question if this plan remained as an
interim plan and had not been finalized
between this discussion in October of
2017 and the onset of the covert
pandemic that would surprise you and
that would be something which uh you
would uh not approve of
I wouldn't approve of that but I would
say that my understanding is that it
worked rather well
um without you know in the sense that we
practiced it in 2018 and 2019 uh through
actual uh lived experience of of
pathogens that were handled through that
pathway so my
surprise is that it wasn't finalized and
yes I would be I would not be happy that
it had not been
um
finalized thank you I want to tend to
ask you some questions now about the
hcid program this was
um a network that was established in
2015 2016 at least in part due to the
need to estab need for it to be
established during Ebola specialized
facilities around the UK where patients
with highly infectious or transmittable
diseases could be treated and is it
correct Mr Selby that in the United
Kingdom a high consequence infectious
disease is defined according to the
following criteria it's an acute
infectious disease that typically has a
high case fatality rate may not have
effective treatment and is often
difficult to recognize or detect rapidly
is has has the ability to spread in the
community and within Health Care
settings and requires an enhanced
individual rule population and system
response to ensure it's managed
effectively efficiently and safely
thank you is it right that both SARS and
MERS have been defined as
hcids
yes I believe so
and it may seem like an obvious question
Mr Selby but why do hcids require a
different response plan compared to
other infectious diseases like influenza
I think because it is they are by
definition rare which is one of the
criteria that they are genuinely unusual
and this was one of the great strengths
of putting down and Colony deals we had
specific facilities to be able to
quickly
uh know what it is we were dealing with
uh quick was really important because
you know if you had something that was
terribly violent you needed to get the
staff properly protected and fast so
these things don't happen that often but
when they do the thing is to contain
them and to manage them
um
um read a class for that what happened
with you know c19 all right thank you in
an annual remit letter from the dhsc to
phe for the year of April 2016 to March
2017. there is this entry working with
government and NHS England to develop a
joint program of work and production of
plans for the public health systems
response to high consequence infectious
disease incidents expect to be completed
in 2017 till 2018 with interim outputs
throughout 2016 to 2017. now that
suggests a clear intention for the
system to be in place by 2017-2018.
but the inquiry understands that as of
March 2017 that work had not been
completed and the system had not been
set up is that something which you have
personal knowledge of
um
I had no idea but may I just quickly say
that we had what you called a quarterly
accountability meeting with the
Department of Health where we would
review progress against all the
different elements of the remit letter
uh those are of course on track those
that were ahead and those that were not
and what we were doing about those that
were not so I expect the department of
health will have a record of that
particular matter and what the uh uh
what was the the story about that at
that time
um it was public health England that
um asked for an
DPR R element to those course of the
accountability reviews because it was
such an important part of our work but
it may I can I decline to say I don't
know I can't say but I do know who would
know if you like and that would be the
Department of Health thank you
exercise Broad Street which took place
in January of 2018
was an exercise sponsored by the hcid
program board and in it phe and NHS
England participated and an observer
from dhsc also attended it was a
discussion-based exercise conducted at
phe colindale in London to consider the
future definitive hcid service in
England and the challenges that an hcid
incident could present professional
partners with
um
do you remember that exercise taking
place Mr Selby
well only because I've read about it in
the evidence pack
that I wasn't personally involved at
that time you will have read then that
one of the concerns raised during the
exercise was that the total turnaround
time for getting a diagnosis was 24
hours which was considered to be too
long and the aim was to try and reduce
that time to below six hours which would
improve the efficiency and cost
effectiveness of the service
one of the strongly featured comments
was about getting patient samples from
the point of sampling to the testing
laboratory and at that time it required
a courier service which was neither
optimal nor consistent across England
and one delegate you will have read was
quoted as saying we recognized this for
years we need a common Courier system
that has capacity
a preference was also expressed for near
patient sample testing because multiple
sample testing locations could reduce
transport time their boy thereby
reducing total diagnostic turnaround
times and it was suggested that
transferring samples to phe Porton may
not be optimal due to its geographical
location and that a northern and
southern Hub would be a more viable
option
um
Dame Jenny Harris told us in her witness
statement that the hcid program was
closed in April of 2018.
do you remember the closing of that
program taking place
and I I not at that time but again I've
read the uh the the you included in the
evidence part the minute of the meeting
that if you like recognized that
decision can I say that I agree with all
of that about the need to have
probably a small number but
geographically uh sensible capability
around the country so that it wasn't all
dependent on getting a sample into
Wiltshire I do know as you know that we
do have these Laboratories
um in um I'll get it wrong but
Manchester Bristol and Birmingham but
anyway and memberly test but it's there
for with four centers I think that's
capability I'm sure with that I knew
about the number just about where the
with with in Cambridge as well
um so
um and and I I'm very surprised they
would take 24 these days it would take
24 hours to do anything
um of that of that nature what I want to
ask you about Mr selfie is is is what
happened to to this particular issue as
well as other matters that were raised
during the course of the program about
Community sampling and diagnostic
testing and guidance when the program
was shut down who took over those issues
partly raised in this exercise and
partly part of the the work stream that
was created during the course of the
hcid program
so I'm afraid I can't help with why was
the program closed Dean Jenny Paris was
what we called the SRO which meant she
was responsible
for making sure that any actions that
flowed from that hadn't been completed
was put into what we might call business
as usual be picked up through the eprr
oversight and the delivery team
supporting brought up to and the
management team as necessary I never had
any cause for concern or raised with me
at any point
that there was a um a need for my
intervention
um I was I was content I mean I was I
was supported by an exceptional talented
team I mean I'm I'm not going to talk
through all of them but of course Jenny
was one of them but I had many Journeys
who were professionally at the high you
know so if I if and they were all very
capable of coming to me and saying if
they were concerned about an outstanding
action or some investment that they
needed right no no no to my memory no no
such concerned raised
given what we've just seen about
concerns raised over the timing of of
testing did you during your stewardship
of Public Health England ever look into
contracts with private Laboratories to
assist with surge testing
no no
um we did lots of work
um through as you talked yesterday with
Jim Jenny about our
[Music]
um
income that we generated commercially
and you know providing that was within
um Health protection you know what it
was like skills and capabilities that we
had or wish to develop then we would
work with whoever uh wanted to work with
us and that would include the private
sector but there was never any uh
discussion
um in in those years
um about using the private sector in
that way do you think that there should
have been
you know not particularly there was no
um
there was no I mean Public Health
England didn't regulate or um accredited
or
um in
in any way
um it constrain the private sector or
any academic
um provider of laboratory science from
doing what they wish to do providing
they could meet the standards set by the
health and safety executive so of course
there's lots of private laboratory work
um but it wasn't necessary in that
context at that time for public health
microbiology we had sufficient
capabilities sufficient capacity for the
um for what was asked of us I I mean I I
love the private sector they've got so
much to offer they've got so much to
give but in that in that context in that
setting it wasn't it wasn't an issue it
wasn't necessary but but looking at the
phe pandemic flu strategy of 2014 and
the the the UK pandemic flu strategy of
2011. it wasn't it obvious that a a huge
expansion of testing would have been
necessary if if that had come to
fruition and that the existing
capability that Public Health England
had over those years was not
sufficiently scalable
no that was not my understanding
um that if we had had an influenza
pandemic Public Health England was
genuinely perfectly capable of doing
this detection assessment the creation
of the test and roll out of that the
Assumption was
um that the go-to for clinical
Diagnostics was the NHS and if you look
at Healthcare Systems around the world
it's the healthcare system that provides
the clinical Diagnostics not the public
health system to my knowledge that it's
not a public health agency that does
clinical Diagnostics anywhere in the
world their CDC us the China CDC from
Pakistan to Ethiopia
that clinical Diagnostics is a health
care responsibility so there was never
any requirement of what public health
microbiology does is is research
surveillance
and um and
um
oh forgive me
um but the initial the initial
diagnostic of the what what the pathogen
is and then making sure people know
um what what what they need to do but
but it would not it is not right that
there was ever any assumption that
public health income could require Mass
testing capability for the influenza
strategy
it was reference capability that I was
searching for reference reference
reference surveillance and research yes
moving back please to the system of
subsidiarity what would Public Health
England's responsibilities so far as
local risk assessment and local pandemic
planning were concerned
well this was principally through
something created again I
local Health resilience Partnerships
created in 2013 which were a creature
based on local resilience forums that
have preceded
um for you know quite large geographical
areas and they covered the same areas
that the police and the fire service and
others covered but there's lots and lots
of Partners in Health as you have have
gathered so the local Health resilience
partnership was a way of like focalizing
that at a local level and that was
jointly chaired between uh a local
Authority within the area so director of
Public Health and NHS England Public
Health England advised uh attended where
possible but essentially local risk
assessment was and the management of and
response was through the local Health
resilience Partnerships I'm trying to
remember my acronyms and there was a
very powerful contribution from public
health England about expertise
and the sharing of sort of
good practice and so on but that was
handled locally between the NHS and and
local government so would public
forums or the local authorities in terms
of their own assessment locally of
pandemic risks and that sort of thing
yes yes and in 2018
um we produced it with the association
of directors of Public Health uh good
practice guidance for the jointly for
for uh for local authorities in the NHS
did Public Health England ever assess
whether or not the local resilience
forums or the local authorities were
were themselves performing an acceptable
risk assessments and and had in place
adequate and responsible plans for for a
pandemic hitting
yes we did and we were asked to do that
by the health select committee I
mentioned this earlier and so we were if
you like
um detailed by the Department of Health
to undertake
uh such an exercise
um it was quite sensitive because local
government and not national government
they are government in their own right
and they're quite protective of who
comes along and audits what it is
they're doing so it took us a short
while but we did agree an exercise with
local government and with the NHS which
was completed in 2016. it was anonymized
for the purposes of the the the what got
published but everybody got to see their
own results and then there was
discussion that went on between the
center or the region of Public Health
England the local area team or whatever
they were called at the time in the NHS
and with them with local government that
was published by the health select
committee I think in 2018
there was a plan to refresh that uh
assessment in 2020 which then never
happened because of covert
and did the pandemic preparedness and
planning that fell to local authorities
include plans for social care
yes well local government are largely
responsible for social care
um and so yes yes
um to the extent that they did I I don't
you know I I can almost I can almost
imagine what you're going to ask me next
well I'd like to put to you something
which Matt Hancock told the inquiry this
morning which was when the pandemic
struck he was told that local
authorities were required to have
Pandemic preparedness plans and when he
asked to see them his Minister for
social care found out that there were
only two local authorities which had
reported to
to to have these plans in place which he
considered to be holy and adequate just
like your reflection on that evidence
but so would I if that was the the
actual case but I'm I've just I just
I've just said you know 2016 we assured
that these local Health resilience
Partnerships all 36 of them had plans
that that they were assessed against I
think 13 criteria I can't tell you
social care was one of them but they
were then if you like uh peer-reviewed
they were externally assured and they
were published and followed through
um I think if I didn't listen to the
Secretary State this morning the former
secretary of state but I would
definitely I would definitely concur
that we you know social care was just
not on our radar
um and and there's no
um
getting away from that
to what extent did Public Health England
engage with other public health agencies
in the devolved Nations
oh regularly um we had a we had very
regular car we had networks for health
protection
so I had a professors support cosford
who you know late died of
um very profoundly senior and much loved
directive Health protection and he would
coordinate the uh colleagues in in the
in the four nations we talked about lots
of other things
um I went personally to Cardiff and
Edinburgh and Belfast on quite a regular
basis and we um and we we basically we
we uh we you know we cared for each
other
um you know there was no uh there was
there was no uh
uh you know we we shared openly
um and public health England was like
you know the mothership for
um you know satin certain capabilities
that you you wouldn't be able to
replicate everywhere
very available to the four nations
I want to turn now to ask you about
public health resilience and health
inequalities and you've already made a
reference to Professor Sir Michael
Marmot who as you probably know has
given evidence to this inquiry together
with Professor Claire bambra on the
issue of Health inequalities the
inquiries also received as you know a
statement from the editor-in-chief of
the Lancet Richard Horton who talks in
his witness statement of
um the fact that the science that has
guided government responses has come
mostly from infectious disease
specialists in epidemic modelers who
understandably frame the health
emergency in terms of their two
disciplines but he he talks about the
fact that what happened with covid was
not really a pandemic but was twin
epidemics clustered together because
covid-19 itself was very challenging but
when you take that into account in terms
of the the state of the health of the
nation and that then that made it even
more difficult to cope with do you agree
with that
I do he actually used the phrase endemic
endemic
and I uh I know my academic
qualifications are uh marginal but I did
publish uh in the last year with the num
with the deputy director general of The
Who on this issue
um on uh it wasn't a pandemic as such it
was a syndemic for all the reasons that
are set out by
uh Michael mammo and I said earlier that
I was very taken by what Richard Horton
had to say because he's right you know
um you have to you have to take account
of all of these if you want to truly
make a difference you can't just say you
know we'll do something that
cardiovascular disease or cancer if
you're not doing it for those that are
most vulnerable
the people at most risks so I won't get
back on tonight
um but essentially I completely and
utterly agree with that
um
thank you I'd like to display please uh
document 211268
which is a report of the inquiry panel
on Health Equity for the north of
England chaired by Margaret Whitehead
it's entitled due north reported the
inquiry of Health Equity for the North
and it's dated September of 2014. and if
we could look please at page six which
explains why the report was commissioned
it says this
life is not Grim up North but on average
people here get less time to enjoy it
because of poorer Health many people in
the north have shorter lifetimes and
longer periods to Ville Health than in
other parts of the country that Health
inequalities exist and persist across
the north of England is not news but
that does not mean that they are
inevitable while the focus of the
inquiry is on the North it will be of
interest to every area and the country
as a whole and then it talks about the
fact that the inquiry was commissioned
by public health England do you remember
this inquiry being commissioned just
pause there oh yes
sir sorry forgive me for interrupting
um roughly how long more this is my
final topic I do know that um
permission has been provisionally
granted to covered bereaved families for
justice to ask about one topic
I'm wondering if it might sense when I
gather the stenographers having a tough
time not surprised
um
given we've got about
five or ten minutes left
five minute break or would you longer
would a five minute break be enough you
sure
so remember that question I will keep it
in my mind I'll be back in five minutes
foreign
lady Mr Selby can you see and hear me
again
yes I can
oh there's this I think there's a slight
delay between the um the picture that we
have of you and the sound but I'm going
to I'm going to carry on because I only
have so few questions left now I think
it might have caught up now in an event
um could we display page 30 please of
this report which I hope will show us
two maps
of the life expectancy amongst males and
females by local Authority between 2009
and 2012 females on the left males on
the right and we can see that the red
areas show the lowest life expectancy on
both maps and they are pretty much
mirrored one to the other
and yes the the
findings as to the causes of Health
authorities are at page 74. can we have
a look at that please
we can see on the left hand side
that
the inquiries overarching assessment of
the main causes of The observed problem
of Health inequalities within and
between north and south are differences
in poverty power and resources needed
for health differences in exposure to
health damaging environments such as
poorer living and working conditions and
unemployment differences in the chronic
disease and disability left by the
historical Legacy of heavy industry and
its Decline and differences in
opportunities to enjoy positive Health
factors and protective conditions that
help maintain Health such as good
quality early years education
economic and food security controls over
decisions that affect your life social
support and feeling part of the society
in which you live
now the inquiry recognizes that some of
the recommended actions in this report
could only be taken forward by central
government but if we look at
recommendation for which is at page 19
there were specific actions identified
for public health England
thank you to conduct a cumulative
assessment of the impact of welfare
reforms and cuts to local and National
Public Services
to support local authorities to produce
a health inequalities risk mitigation
strategy
to help to establish a
cross-deportmental system of health
impact assessment
to support the involvement of health and
well-being boards and public health
teams in the governance of local
Enterprise Partnerships and combined
authorities to contribute to a review of
current systems for the central
allocation of public resources to local
areas
to support the development of a network
of health and well-being boards across
the north of England with a special
focus on Health Equity and to
collaborate on the development of a
chartered to protect the rights of
children
now I I don't seek to ask you Mr Selby
to deal with each of those
recommendations individually but given
that these were present in a report in
2014 are you able in Broad terms to
explain what action Public Health
England took to reduce these Health
inequalities in the north of England
after these recommendations were
received
I think this is one of actually a number
of reports and by public health thinking
and direct looking at the health of the
nation
um and the issue about the north is not
that it
um possesses it's a thing it's about
intensity there are inequalities
everywhere but the intensity is greater
so I remember very well it does feel
like a long time ago but that we had
regional response because we had the
regional director for the north uh who
worked with uh Margaret and local
authorities who had a lot of a lot of
the influence here with the city
um
in particular for Manchester but there
were other Mayors Liverpool that we were
speaking to about the sort of expert
advice and support of Public Health Inc
provide
um this is ultimately an issue of
resources
um I I you know we we were not we were
not able to make the sort of Investments
happen that would that would make the
biggest difference here it's a it's um
it's it's evident that you know these
inequalities remain as tough and maybe
whitening uh if Professor Marmot is is
right about about this public health
England was not in their position to
direct resources but we were in a
position to highlight and make
transparent if you like bring visibility
to this uh and about you know the
actions that might make the latest
difference and Jen I am I'm trying very
hard not to rumble along but we did
produce all sorts of evidence about what
would make the biggest difference for
those that were in these circumstances
that Margaret Whitehead
um describes
thank you
that question but
but that over the course of the 10 years
preceding the covert pandemic that life
expectancy and in particular healthy
life expectancy worsened for those who
were living in poverty
I think that's a very reasonable
position
and so during the life of Public Health
England
who you believe that it succeeded in its
mission to reduce Health inequalities
um
evidently not
um but what we did do was as they draw
make make it transparent bring it into
Consciousness we produced
um evidence reviews we gave advice we
try to get government to focus on the
things that would make the biggest
difference we made good progress in
certain areas like TB and HIV and Hep C
um we made less good progress in areas
like childhood obesity but it wasn't for
the want of Public Health England we
made advice available on all sorts of
areas that this report speaks to
including air quality and gambling and
pretty much everything in between but in
my witness statement I make the point
that politics and public health are
inseparable that you you simply can't
get these sorts of things addressed
without political commitment not just
about money but about the commitment to
do difficult
um and and difficult is difficult for
governments
um there's been particularly difficult
for this government and we've seen
um so I would say evidently inequalities
have not improved and therefore we have
not succeeded in our mission but I would
not accept that it wasn't for one of
trying and for drying out the evidence
about if you did this you could expect
to see this impact and finally
people publish things they say things
they they go
um out and they say what they care about
but these days
I'm not interested in that I'm
interested in show me your budget and
then I'll know what you care about
don't show me your strategy and don't
tell me that you care about health
Improvement in inequalities show me your
budget and then I'll know whether you do
and I'm afraid that that I would say
that that that there has not been a
sufficient interest and focus because
the spending does not reflect that
thank you Mr Selby
my lady
that completes
um my questioning and um subject to my
lady confirming that covered bereave
families for justice do have permission
to ask a question around the chief
nursing officers meeting of October 2014
and then I will hand over to miss Monroe
King's Council Miss Monroe
um
thank you my lady um the question is in
fact that was yesterday's question
I thought I was having Deja Vu
I went over to you I was wondering how
it was going to uh it's in relationship
sorry she didn't mislead me thank you
Mr Selby can you um hear and see me
yes I can miss Monroe thank you very
much
um I ask questions on behalf of covert
buried families for justice throughout
the country
it is in relation to a document that um
you have already been referred to today
the MERS plan I wonder if we could have
that on the screen please it's ironq
triple zero one seven nine oh six nine
can you see that Mr Selby I I can yes oh
that's actually the meeting it's the
document itself
I'm told it's inq triple Z
eroes
you can see the document yes I can yes
thank you it's entitled Public Health
England response plan for possible
presumptive and confirmed MERS cases
and
purpose of it's a guidance and the
purpose is that it's an internal
document to be used by phe quote to
inform planning for potential MERS cases
yes now
this was from 2017
um it's during a period of time of your
um tenure with phe would you agree Mr
Selby that
that particular plan sets out in some
considerable detail
matters such as infection control
guidance and management of both
symptomatic and significantly
asymptomatic MERS patients and
healthcare workers
would you also agree Mr Selby that when
and again we don't need to bring it on
the screen because it's a guidance
you're familiar with
but for reference purposes my lady it's
page 14 of the guidance it includes
measures within this guidance that we
all became very familiar with during the
course of 2020 and they include
isolation and self-isolation in the
community contact tracing Communications
and restricting interactions between
those affected and The Wider public such
as transport restrictions
prohibitions of
attendance in public spaces Etc that's
all part and parcel of the guidance
isn't it
yes
now appreciating Mr Selby what you have
said this afternoon in answer to
questions
from Miss Blackwell about this MERS plan
that there needed to be clarification
with UK HSA
that not be standing given that covid-19
was initially classified as an Airborne
hcid would you have expected the MERS
plan to have been utilized in some form
for covid-19 as it had been for MERS and
monkey pox as you've referenced and are
you able to say whether it was in any
form utilized
yes and yes so what you were describing
would be a regular Health protection
activity at a scale that we were well
used to to dealing with
um it is my understanding that the hcid
pathway was in fact utilized for the
early cases of covid yes
thank you very much Mr silby thank you
my lady those are my questions thank you
very much
foreign
y that completes the evidence of Mr
Selby and the evidence for today
thank you very much
to affected your day too disastrously
and thank you very much for your help
thank you thank you
10 o'clock tomorrow thank
you 10 o'clock tomorrow thank you